안녕하십니까 인편 여러분. 행복한
투자 회정을 함께하는 체슬리 모닝
브리프 금요일 6월 26일 1부
시작하겠습니다.
어 즐거운 금 주말인데요.
먼저 주말이 되기 전 그 목요일 중국
시장은 어떻게 됐는지 왕부장님께
들어보겠습니다.네 [목을 가다듬음]
>> 요새는 기술주 강세하면 상실주 플러스
23% 올라왔고요. 흥성 지수는
웨너스 1.5% 빠지고 정시 거대는
3.5조 수준을 유지했어요. 업종별
좀 보시면 어젠뮤케이션 피 소비제
업정 간세표하고 반면도 소비제
에너지요 디dt 업정 약세
배웠습니다.이 IT 커뮤니케이션
쪽으로 보시면 어제는 IT 업종은
4.7% 올라왔고요. 그리고
커뮤니케이션 쪽으로는 3.7%
올라왔습니다. 영양초로 보면은 IT는
영양 영초 대비 99%이 섹터는
올라왔고요.
>> 커뮤니케이션 섹터는 72% 정도
급등했어요.
어 글로벌 IT 섹터 동조화 그리고
케파 화대 등률 IT 관련주 어제를
검색고요. 보방 화천은 3.5%
올라고 조이테크는 9.9% 9%
종사는
자정 2% 정전테크는 10% 모두
역사는 신고이 필요하고요. 보방
화천는 어제 기종으로 그냥 100조
넘어갔습니다. 영초 대비
74%왔어요.
이번에 실적 기대감 금요 출라대형
세상 조전도로 광동신 권령 조도
강세되었습니다. 동제 5천 염증 9%
신역선능 9.9% 9% 천부 건식
5% 올라왔어요. 정시 거대 회복
그리고 대형 기대감으로 증권주 어제를
컨셉되었습니다. 중심 증권은 4%
동망 제보는 자 5% 올라왔어요.
CCR 가격은 추가 인상 루버가 지금
나오고 있습니다. 아마 다음 주 그
킹보트 그 회사가 이번 달 이미 지점
전날 이미 상조 좀 했잖아요. 뭐가
15% 인사했잖아요.
>> 라미네이트
>> 맞아요. 맞아요. 아마 다음 주는
10%부터 15% 정도 인상 가능성이
좀 있어요. 그래서 다음 주을 그때
좀 봐야 합니다. 그래서 어제는
CC와 PCP 권용주 다
급등했습니다. 승인 테크는 5.5%
동생 청률 73% 호전 조심 8%
올라왔어요.
어 요리 선묘적으로는 그 권영쪽 계속
급등하고 있습니다. 중국 거는
9.2%하고요. 벗고요. 푸니가 우리
처음으로 그 리서할 때는 그때
주각보다는 이미 그로 났습니다.
>> 어 종재 테크는 10% 올라고 구제
부제는 요즘 5% 올라왔습니다. 해용
MLCG 가격 급등 소시에 따라서
MLCG 관련주 어제도 강세
고여고요. 그 선마 정는 13%
가까이 올라왔고요. 폭화 테크는
10% 상한가 기록했습니다. 요가하라
그리고 위안화 절선등 허재인버 황주
어제도 강제 보였고요. 충구 한
6.3%하고 난방는 요청 3% 충구
동방는 7% 상승했습니다. 반면
에너지 유기 바워주들이 좀 빠졌고요.
어 신염물 구체 금리 어제 염정
7bp 하러 있습니다. 이념물 구체
금리 1.4pp bp 상승하고 외한화
환율의 염증이 2% 잘성되었습니다.
>> 감사합니다.
>> 예. 어, 우리 광부장님이 어저께
창업 조심해라 그랬는데 창업판이 또
많이 올랐어요.
>> 어, 마이. [웃음]
>> 예.
>> 농담이고요.이 증시가 방향성이 있을
때는 당연히
>> 어, 조금 더 베타가 높은 그런 어,
지수가 있죠. 창업판이 좀 그런 거
같고. 오늘 좀 중국 매크로 관련해서
하나 간단하게 여쭤보고 넘어가려고
하는데요. 네. 한국 시장도 미국
시장도 진짜 오르는 종목만
오르거든요. 그래서 한국도 심한
경우에는 전체 종목 중에 한 10%
정도만 오를 때도 있고 그니까 지수는
상승하는데 오르는 종목이 한
10%밖에 없을 때도 있고 그러니깐
[콧방귀]
>> 어 메모리 중심으로 굉장히 압축돼서
오른다고 볼 수 있는데 미국도 예외는
아닌 거 같습니다. 중국도 제가
이렇게 신문 같은 거 보다 보면
A 아 반도체 굵기, 테크 굴기 뭐
이런 거 관련해서는 주로 우리
왕부장님이 소개시켜 주신 것처럼 아주
좋긴 한데
>> 내수가 부진하고 전반적인 경제가 막
잘 돌고 그러는 거 같진 않아요.
그래서 그런 쪽 그러니까 경기를 좀
활성화시키고 내세를 진작시키기 위해서
정부가 아마 노력을 많이 할 텐데
>> 그렇게 관련한 종목을 추천해 주실
만한 거는 없나 좀 궁금했습니다.
>> 아 이게 이게 있는데요. 뭐 좋은
회자가 꽤 많아요. 뭐 규즈모 컨센트
이런 좌게 좋고요.이
>> 규즈모적으로 보시면 지금 후드 피어는
17배 밥 없어요.
그냥 MC 마주 50%이잖 나올 수
있는 회사 자사주도 계속 매입하고
주적 화면에도 강화되고 있고 센슨트
이런 회사는 약간 그 지금음
이게 뭔가 돈 조달하고 써야 하는
기업이잖아요. 다만 그 멀티플
11배가 지금 나갔어요.
[목을 가다듬음] 열배 미만 하는
테크 회사입니다. 이런 회사는 다
소외되고 있습니다. 그래서 현후에
뭐이 반체이 사이클는 진정되고 어 뭐
중국 경기 회포되면 아마 그런 회사는
좀 많이 올라갈 수 가능성이 있다고
생각해.
>> 지나치게 주목받는 업종이나 종목들이
너무 비싸져 있던지 아니면 그
반대편에서 좀 터너라운드의 기운이
나오던지 주시기를 좀 기다려
보겠습니다. 네.
>> 어 본 적 있는 기업 같아요. 대족
레이저.
>> 네. 대초 레이저 회사가 어 원리
지난달 한번 그 발표했어요.이 회사가
그때 주가 대비는 70% 정도
급등했어요. 한 달 미만이 시간 내
70% 급등했습니다. 글로벌 레이저
장비 시전은 그냥 MS 9% 충구
1등 유지하고 글로벌 300입니다.
지원 매출 구성적으로 보시면 PCB
전비 30% 증자 전 장비는 13%
기타 레이저는 전비는 95% 정도
되고요. 1번에 매출했는 동의 대비
74% 순위 있는 동의 대비는 12%
정도 급등했어요. 그때는 시장
예산보다 두게 나오고요. GP
마주률는 34% 정도 되고 MP 마율
8.5% 5% 정도 동의를 다
화퇴했습니다. 슬게
[콧방귀][목을 가다듬음] 나오는
이유는 그 거마진 PCB 장비 사업부
거장 그리고 증자 2차 정지 정비
사업부 회복이 두 가지 그 요인
때문에 10점는 계속 좋게 나오고
있습니다. 1분기 PCB 정비 사업부
매출에는 동의 정도 급등 급증을
했어요.이 차부 GP 33% 정도
나오고 있고요. 요즘에 그 PCB
관련 회사들이 다 대규 뭐 정절하고
있잖아요. 다이 회사가 정비 써야
됩니다. 그래서이 장비는 슈티지
상황을 발생하고 있고요. 어 원래
1월부터 5월까지 수준은 동기 대비
150%했어요.
>> 그 1월보다 4월 수주 동기 대비는
90% 정도 돼요.
>> 그래서 이거 한 달 갔는 또
150%까지 확대했습니다.이 전비
지금 구매해도 2027년 말 그대로
받을 수 있어요. 그래서이 슈팅치
상호는 계속 심어지고 있습니다.
>> 어 시티 중관사 리포트 엊그제
나왔습니다. 어제 나왔습니다. PCB
건모듈 애플 서비스 결제 수요 확대에
따라서 매수 의견을 제시했습니다. 1
PCB 시장 경우는 상향 조정에
따라서 PCB 그리고 권리시버 관련
장비 수육을 증가하고 있고요. 그리고
애플 교체 사이클도 진입했습니다.
원래는 첫 폰 출시 예정이고 내년은
아이폰 20주년 있었네요. 그래서
새로운 그 업그레이드 기대할 수
있습니다. 따라서 원래부터 내년 내
홍년 매출에는 지정 대비 가가 1%
2% 상형 조정하고는 가까 1% 3%
정도 상승했습니다.
장비 상승이클 진입에 따라서 타케는
49배에서 55배로 상승했어요.
177 정도 제시했습니다. 어 지전
대비 14% 상승 조하고요. 이년
EPS CGR는 44% 나오고 있고
PG는 1.600입니다.
>> 음. 네.
지금 장비주는 PG
뭐 관점로 보면은 대충 다 1.6배
2배로 보고 있잖아요. 그래서 만약에
여기서 전체 업종 평균 PH의
1.6배까지 커버할 수 있으면 어
멀티블는 대충은 30% 정도 없애던
30% 정도 나올 수 있어요.
>> 네. [콧방귀] 퀴즈라는게
네. [웃음]
>> 맞아요. 네.
>> 네. 어, 두 배, 세 배 이렇게
되는 거는 어, 이익 성장률보다 높은
멀티플을 받는 어떤 이유가 있어야
되는 건데 그 이유들이 지금은
성장성인 거 같아요. 어떤 다른
기업보다 압도적인 경제적 해자를 갖고
있다거나
>> 어, 대체 불과하다거나 뭐 그런
기업도 물론 있겠습니다만
>> 지금 페이지가 1배 이상 훌쩍 넘어서
거래되는 대부분의 기업은
>> 해당 업종에 대한 기대감 성장성이
아닌가 하는 생각이 듭니다. 어,
대저 좋은 기업이고 밑에 보니까
멀티플이 전부 다 이렇게 고점을 막
갱신하고 있는 거 봐서는 시장도 이미
인지하고 있는 거 같은데.
>> 네.
>> 어,이 종목을 오늘 발표를들은 우리
채밀턴 여러분들이 한국 시장에서 얻을
수 있는 힌트는 무엇입니까?
>> 아,
>> 중국의 직접 투자이라.
>> 어. 네.이 찰 수 있으니까 차분.
왜냐면 그 처 우리 그 얘기하는
처음반 있잖아요. 처음반는 개인 투자
할 수 없는
>> 그 시장입니다. 산더 시작하는 호자가
개인 투자자 살 수 없 외국인 개인
투자자 할 수 없고요. 우리 기관은
잘 수 있고요.
>> 그래서이 호자는 좀 분위가 영웅부터
시작이잖아요. 이거는 외국인 살 수
있는 호자입니다. 그래서 저
>> 편합니다. 피커의 어떤 규제나 이런
것들이 들어가 있구나.
>> 네. 그 시장 세분화로 되고 있고요.
>> 산포다 시작하는 거는 그 외국인 할
수 없는 시장이
>> 그럼 맨 앞자리가 뭐뭐가 있어요?
0이고 욕부터 시작하는 거고 0부터
시작하는 거 있습니다.음
>> 0 3 6네
>> 맞아요.음
>> 그러면 0은 외국인도 접근 가능하고
3은 안 되고
>> 맞습니다. 아 3은 안 6은
>> 6 가능하고요. 그냥 688 시작하면
안 되고 688 시작하면 안돼.
>> 네. 요 80 시작하면 안 됩니다.
>> 음. 어렵다. [웃음]
>> 어쨌든 이거는 영어로 시작하는 걸로
봐서는 된다.
>> 아, 맞습니다.
>> 네. 알겠습니다. 한국의 비슷한
기업이나 뭐 경쟁 기업이나 대체 이런
것들은 없는 모양입니다. 알겠습니다.
중국 시장에 이렇게 반짝반짝하는
종목들이 있어서 제 주변에도 항상
종국 투자 재미 없잖아라고 얘기하는
분들은 이제 지수 보고하시는 분
있으니까
>> 이렇게 그 옐로우칩 그리고 지수
관련이 아닌 종목들을 가지고 높은
수익을 낼 수 있다는 것 저도 계속
홍보하고 있습니다. 중국 시장
여기까지 보고요. 전일 미국 시장
보도록 하겠습니다. 유리프로 님
부탁드립니다.
>> 네. 어 25일 끝난 미국장
말씀드리도록 하겠습니다. 어제
마이크론 실적 발표 [목을 가다듬음]
이후에 좀 시간에서 주가가 강하게
반등했다라고 어제 되게 강조를
드렸었는데요. 그러면서 뭐 오르지
않을 이유가 없는 장이다. 제가
이렇게 말씀드렸던 거 같은데 지수
쪽부터 보시면 S&P 500 같은
경우에는 보합으로 마감을 했고
나스닥은 소폭 하락하면서 끝난
하루였습니다.
>> 좀 뒤어 말씀드리긴 하겠는데요.
메가캡의 약세가 좀 이유였
이유였습니다. 이제 러셀 2원
보시면은 0.7% 7% 상승을 했고
근데 이것보다는 중소형주의 신규
매수세가 유입되었다기보다는 전일에
이제 2% 넘게 빠졌기 때문에 이제
일부 되돌림을 보인 것에 가깝다로
보이고요. 다만 이제 그래도 심리는
살아 있는게 오른쪽에 10년물 이미지
차트 보시면 4.3%대 좀 안정적으로
안착학을 어제이어서 하고 있고 또
빅테크 위주에 메가캡이 좀 약세였지만
다우 지수 자체는 또 소폭 상승을
했고요. SP 500 그리고 러셀이
상대적으로 좀 버텼다라는 점은 보면
위험 선호가 완전히 꺾인 장은
아니었지만 지수 전체를 뭐 밀어 올릴
만큼의 확신도 좀 부족했던
장이었다라고 먼저 분위기 짚어 드릴
수 있을 것 같습니다. 그래서 이렇게
분위기 점검상 어제 이제 발표된 PC
개인 소비 지출 물가 지수랑 금리
체크부터 먼저 좀 해보고 들어가려고
하는데 이제 어제 이제 5월 PC
물가 지수랑 [목을 가다듬음]
>> 그 개인 소비 그리고 개인 소득
그리고 1분기 GDP 확정치랑 수정가
좀 발표가 됐는데요. 이제 5월 PC
물가 같은 경우에는 아래쪽에 전원
텍스트로만 정리드렸는데 우선 전년
대비해서는 4.1% 상승을 했습니다.
전널이었던 3.8%보다 높아졌고
2023년 이후로 가장 높은
수준이었다고 하고요. 또 에너지처럼
변동성이 큰 항목을 제외한 이제 근원
PC죠. 여기도 제 근원 PC도 보면
전년 대비 3.4% 상승을 했습니다.
동시에 1분기 GDP도 뭐 연
2.1% 성향 성장하면서 좀 상향
수정이 됐습니다.이
이 지표까지 그래서 총합해서 보시면은
뭐 성장은 좀 버티고 근데 물가는
아직 좀 높은 조합에 가까웠다라고
말씀드릴 수 있을 것 같은데 그래서
수치들만 보면은 좀 물가가 너무
높아지는 거 아니야라고 좀 우려는
가능하실 거 가능할 것 같지만 뭐
PC가 상승하면서 GDP도 근데
동시에 상향 조장이 됐기 때문에 뭐
개인 소비랑 소득이 모두 증가하면서
물가는 높지만 소비는 아직 버틴다라는
해석이 가능할 것 같습니다. 그리고
이걸 보여주는 이제 데이터가 좀 국채
금리일 거 같은데요. 우측에 이제
수치로 기재된 좀 국채 금리들 좀
보시면 10년물 4.39% 수준에서
마감을 했고 또 전일 대비 큰 변화는
없었고요. 약간 오르긴 했는데 그
2년물 금리는 4.13%로 좀 소폭
다시 하락을 했습니다. 그래서 이제
이렇게 조합을 보면은 금리는 내렸기
때문에 어제 주식 시장이 뭐 기대만큼
강하지 않았던 뭐 이유가 뭘까를
생각해 보면 뭐 금리 쪽에서 찾기는
어려울 거 같고 오히려 또 시장이
PC가 높게 나오긴 했지만 뭐 예상
범위 안에 있기도 했고 전널 대비
미수치가 또 예상보다 낮았다는 점에
좀 더 반응을 한 것으로 보입니다.
그래서 달러 스팟도 보시면은 달러스팟
한 0.2% 2% 하락을 했는데 뭐
낙폭 자체가 크지 않았기 때문에 뭐
크리티컬하기보다는
뭐 크리티컬하다 혹은 뭐 강한 위험
선기보다는 PC가 이제 높게
나왔음에도 뭐 금리가 급등하지 않은데
따른 제한적인 달러 약세였다 정도로
이제 보시면 될 거 같습니다. 유가도
함께 보시면은 뭐 금리 말씀드렸듯이
안정적이긴 했는데 유가는 조금 다시
올랐습니다. WTI가 배럴당이
72달러 대왔고 브랜드 같은 경우에는
한 75에서 76달러 수준까지
올라왔는데요. 배경은 역시나 이제 뭐
호르무주 헤업 때문이었습니다. 이제
뉴스가 어제 있었는데 선박 지나는
선박 하나가 미화인 발사체에 피격이
됐고 일부 유소전이랑 상선이 호르무
협과를 시도하다가 되돌아섰다라는 이제
소식이 나왔었습니다. 그래서 지난
며칠 동안 호르몬주 통이 좀
정상화되는 분위기였는데 이번 권
통해서 이제 에너지 공급 리스크가 좀
다시 보이 되면서 시장이 좀 예민하게
반응을 했다 정도로 볼 수 있을 것
같고 다만요 부분 아직 책임 주체가
명확하게 확인된 상황은 아니라서 어
전면적인 지정한 리스크
재확산이다라기보다는
뭐 원유 공급 불확실성을 반영한
정도다로 이해해 보시면 될 거
같습니다.
>> 네. 이제 다시 중간부로 이동하셔
가지고 이제 기업단 보실 텐데요.
이제 어제 장의 주인공이 사실
마이크론이었다면 오늘은 좀 빅테크가
아니었나 싶을 정도로 하락을 많이
했는데 마이크론 실적 발표 이후에 뭐
DDR 5랑 랜드 가격 상승 기대감
그 그리고 그 지속성이 더 공공이
되면서 마이크론뿐 아니라 샌디스크 뭐
워스턴 디지털 같은 스토리지 관련주도
강했고 뭐 어플라이드 머티리얼스
램리서치 K 같은 반도체 장비주도 뭐
신고가 이름 올리면서 좀 강했습니다.
그 필반 지수도 어제 3.6% 6%
가량 상승을 했는데 이제 여기서 좀
개별 종목은 강하긴 했는데 지수가
그렇지 못한 점을 왜 이제 다시
찾고자 하는 그 질문으로 돌아오면은
마이크론이 이제 다시 촉발한 주가
호재가 시장 전체로 이제 확산되지
못했구나라는 점이라고 이제 기업단에서
확인해 볼 수 있을 것 같고 앞서
여기서도 말씀드렸듯이 애플이랑
마이크로소프트가 특히 약세를
보여줬습니다. 음
>> 애플이 특히 6.1% 1% 하락하면서
좀 출혈이 컸고 마이크로소프트가
3.5% 하락을 했는데요. 애플 같은
경우는 메모리나 저장 장치 가격
상승을 이후로 어제 맥이나 아이패드
홈디바이스 비점프로 가격을 일제
인상을 했습니다. 뭐 정식 실적
발표나 컴퍼스콜이 있었던 건 아닌데
어제 애플 온라인 스토어 가격 바뀌었
바뀌면서 나온 보도들이 좀 임팩트가
컸던 것으로 추장이 됩니다. 이제
이런 여러 제품의 가격이 동시에 오은
것이라서 뭐 일부 모델 조정이
아니었기 때문에 뭐 메모리나 저장
장치 가격 급등 이제 이유가 딱
기결이 되면서 좀 어 지난 10일 어
아 좀 주가가 반응한 것으로
보입니다. 마이크로소프트도 사실
비슷한 흐름이 있었는데 X박스라는
게임기 콘솔이 있는데이 게임기 콘솔
가격을 추가로 인상을 했습니다.
그래서 근데 그 이유가 역시 저장
장치랑 메모리 가격 상승이었는데요.
지난 10일에 제가 X박스 사업부
인력 축소 예정권을 말씀드렸던 적이
있었는데 이제요 사업부 구조 조정
이수랑 연결해서 보면은 아
이엑박스라는 게임기라는 사업이 초자
대비 좀 낮은 수익성이 다시금 이제
부각이 됐다라는 점도 함께 연결이
되면서 좀 가격 인상 압박 마진이
커졌다. 그리고 또 데이터 센터
쪽으로 메모리가 빠지면서 PC
메모리도 부족하고 그리고 그 부담이
소비자 하드웨어 제품까지 아 전가가
된게 어 그게 그럴까라는 이제 그냥
생각에만 그쳤다면 어제는 좀 제품
가격이 오르면서 확실시됐다라는 좀
점을 좀 볼 수 있을 것 같습니다.
>> 네. 그리고 어 신고가 쪽에 좀 못
보는 종목이 있어 가지고 포티넷이라는
기업이 있는데요. 여기가 메모리나
장비는 아니긴 한데 뭐 데이터 센터
확장 때문에 역시나 이제 다시 언급이
됐던 기업이었습니다. 뭐 이미 좀 뭐
영강 가이던스랑 최근에 이제 발표됐던
뭐 실적 발표 좀 긍정적인 편이긴
했는데 관련해서 어제 직접적인 좀
촉매는 뭐 IBD라는 이제 인베스
비즈니스 데일리라는 보도가 있는데
보도지가 있는데 여기서 이제 뭐 자체
AC 기반 방합 경제력 경쟁력 그리고
뭐 AI 데이터 섹터 확장에 따른
보완 수요에 대해서 보도에서 좀
다시금 짚어줬습니다. 그래서 여기서
이제 뭐이 회사가 A식 칩을
만든다라고 해 가지고 뭐 브로드컴이나
CPU를 만드냐 하면 그거는 또
아니고이 여기서 이제 만드는 A6칩
같은 경우에는 자사 방화벽 장비에
들어가는 뭐 보안 전용 A6 칩이다.
그래서 그 점 참고해 주시면 될 거
같고.
어 그래서 여기서 사실 다 차치하고
기억하실 단어는 보완주라는 단어
하나일 거 같은데 어 또 AI 데이터
센터 수의 범위가 어디까지 확장될지를
이런 데이터를 기반으로 좀 상상력을
발휘해 볼 수 있다라는 점이요 기업이
신고가 찍은 점에서 확인해 볼 수
있을 것 같습니다.
>> 반도체 쪽도 그래도 한번 짚고 가서
보시면은 어제 마이크론 실적 계기로
메모리랑 장비주가 다시 강하게 반등을
했습니다. 마이크론 15.7% 7%
올랐고 메모리랑 스토리지 쪽에서는
이제 샌디스크가 22%나 올랐습니다.
이제 어 A 같은 경우랑 램리 서치를
좀 비교하면서 어 왜 어플라이드
머티리얼스가 더 크게 올랐을까를 좀
궁금해하실 것 같아서 저도 생각을 좀
해 봤는데 아무래도 이제 K팩스
확장에 따라서 반도체 장비주들이 좀
수혜를 보는 구조다 보니까 전반적으로
이제 공장을 계속 짓는 구조고 그만큼
케펙스가 들어가다 보면은 식각에
특화된 이제 포트를 갖고 있는 램리
서치보다 에임이 전반적으로 더 수혜를
볼 수 있지 않을까 하는 논리가 좀
더 적용이 되지 않았을까 정도로 이제
생각을 해 볼 수 있었고 그 특히 할
만합 정도 TSMC가 이제 유일하게
조금 내렸습니다. 어제 TSMC에서
관련해서 뉴스를 좀 찾아봤는데 6월
25일 상해에서 테크놀로지 심포지움이
있었다고 하더라고요. 그래서 여기서
자체 뭐 AI 출론칩인 한라페뉴얼을
공개를 했고 요에 제대로 뭐
TSMC가 맞는다. 오픈 AI에라는
보도가 좀 있어서 뭐 TSMC 선당
공정 수요가 유 유지된다라는 논리
자체는 유지가 됐는데 그럼에도 좀
빠졌던 이유는 뭐 어제 시장의 매수
포인트가 좀 TSMC 같은
파운드리보다는 마이크론 실적에서
확인된 메모리나 장비 쪽 때문
아니었을까 그래서 좀 상대적으로
소외된 모습 보였다라고 좀 생각해 볼
수 있을 것 같습니다.
>> 광학 조도 좀 일부 회복하는 모양세
보였는데요. 좀 최근에 많이 빠졌던
종목들이라서이 인프라체인 회복 흐름
속에서 같이 되돌림 보인 모습으로
보입니다. 그래서 랩업 드리자면 어제
이제 장은 마이크론 실적이 좋았음에도
지수 전체를 끌어지는 못했고 근데
그래서 뭐 약세장 전환이다라기보다는
강조드리듯이 다시 뭐 내부에서
수혜주랑 비용 부담조가 다시 갈린
하루였다. 그리고 빅테크 전체적으로
또 뭐 이게 다 좀 오른
장이었다라기보다는 실제 병목이
발생하고 또 가격 전가력이 있는 쪽을
더 이제 시장이 명확하게 알았고
그리고 그게 애플이랑 마이크로소프트의
이제 가격 뭐 상승 가격을 이제 올
올린 이슈로 좀 징빙된 하루였다
정도로 볼 수 있을 것 같습니다.
이상입니다.
>> 감사합니다. 미국 시장 언제나 이렇게
쭉 말씀 주시면 머릿속에 요약이
됐다고 생각을 하고 있는데 마지막이
마무리 정리를 들으면 아 완벽하게
정리된게 아니었구나 [웃음]
보다 잘 정리를 해 주셔서 항상
감사드립니다. 저는 애플이 6%
하락하는 거 처음 처음은 아닐
거예요. 두 명이 있는데 쉽게 보지
못하는 등락 폭인 것 같아서
>> 시장에서 어떤 좀
>> 어 여러 가지 어 함의를 주는게
아닌가 하는 생각 드는데 아 우리
최밀탄 여러분들이 여기 써 주신
것처럼 애플 가격 올랐다고 안 살
거냐?
>> 속칭 애플 바들이 있는데
>> 그죠?
>> 앱등이라고라는 표현을 쓰더라고.
앱등이 그 뭐의
>> 표는 아닙니다. [웃음]
>> 네. 그래서 또 애플 좋아하시는
분들이나 보유하고 계신 채밀탄
여러분들은 네. 여러 가지 생각을 좀
해 보셔야 하는 하루이지 않을까
생각이 듭니다. 미국 시장 여기까지
보겠습니다. 가상재산으로
넘어가겠습니다. 준혁님.
>> 네. 가선시장 말씀드리겠습니다. 지금
앞자리 보시면 오자로 바뀌었습니다.
어제 [목을 가다듬음] 름이 굉장히
안 좋았는데요. 어 큰 하락이
나오면서 제한 9시 10시 어 방한
11시 정도까지 해서 크게 어
하락하는 모습 보여줬습니다. 어제
그래서 한 58,000불 정도까지
내려왔었다가 다시 한번 좀 회복해서
5만9,000불 6만 불 정도
수준에서 거래가 되고 있는 거
같은데요. 우선 6만 불이 깨지면
반발적으로 매수가 들어오는 거는
확실하게 확인할 수 있는 거
같습니다. 그래서이 구간이 강력하게
어느 부분들이 어 지지하는 선 그리고
사람들이 생각하는 심리적인 어
지지선인 거는 확실한 거 같다라는
생각을 하고 있게 왜냐면 이게 지금
세 번째 트라이하는 건데 한 번도
6만 불 그러니까 6만불 6만 불을
깨고 나서 그 안에서 밑에서 좀 크게
머물렀던 적이 많이 없는 거 같아요.
그냥 어 바로 매수세가 들어오면서
6만불대로 다시 복귀하고 이런
부분들을 보여줬었는데 이번엔 어떻게
흐름이 좀 이어질지 잘 살펴보면 될
거 같고요. 어 크게 하락한 이유를
찾지는 못했습니다. 그렇지만 어제 뭐
로폼 관련된 스트레티지 관련된
이슈들이 계속해서 지속이 되고 있고
자금 조도 관련된 이슈들이 지속이
되고 있다 보니까 그런 센티먼트가
크게 하나 어 부러지더라도 계속해서
큰 악제로 받아들여지는 그리고 크게
움직임이 나오는 그런 모습으로 볼 수
있을 것 같고 오히려 너무 거래량이
없다 보니까 그리고 여기 사람들이
관심이 좀 소외되고 있다 보니까 어
조그만한 뉴스에도 크게 반응해서 그
비트 위아래로 등락포이 좀 큰
모습이다 이렇게 보시는게 좋지 않을까
생각합니다. 어, 오른쪽에 있는
비트코인 장기 차트 보시면 어, 큰
흐름으로 봤을 때 제가이 차트를
가져온 이유가 있는데요.이 가장 밑에
있는 빨간색 선 같은게 어,
200일선입니다.이 밑에서도 간단하게
소개드리겠지만 어,이 200 아
200주선입니다. 200주
이평선인데요. 그 200주 이평선을
어 항상 하해를 했다가 어 위로 다시
지지를 받고 올라가는 모습을 22년
때도 그렇게 한번 보여 줬었는데
결국에 지금이 제가 말씀드리려고 했던
거는 이게이 부분에 지지를 받고
올라간다라는 말씀을 드리려는게
아니고이 부분은 하향 돌파했기 때문에
더 이상 지지로서 역할하는게 아니라이
부분에서 하회하면서 어 갈 확률이
굉장히 크다. 그리고 지금 옆으로
기거나 가격이 폭락한다라는 말씀을
드려는 것보다는 어 옆으로가 옆으로
가격이 희거나 그 기거나 아니면
가격이 약간 좀 계속해서 재미 없을
수 있다. 한 5만 불 정도 수준에서
계속해서 놀다가 바닥을 찾을 확률이
굉장히 크겠다라는 생각은 하고 있고
어 이렇게 가격 흐름이 안 좋으니까
오히려 좀 긍정적인 부분을 계속 찾게
찾으려고 하는 거 같은데요. 어 이런
식으로 큰 이슈가 하나 나와서 폭락이
나와 줘야지이 저희가 생각했던 그
바닥을 찾을 수가 있습니다. 어,
사람들이 바닥에다 바닥에다 했을 때는
절대 바닥이 안 오거든요. 그냥 어,
내 바닥을 거 오히려 기유제 같이
바닥만 찾는 거지 실제로 큰 이슈
사람들이 정말 어, 충격을 받을
정도의 큰 이슈가 하나 나오게
된다라고 하는 바닥이 어, 상
찾아졌습니다. 그 큰 이슈를 저희가
바라는 건 바라고 가는 건 아니지만
어쨌든 그런 역사가 있었다라고 보시면
될 거 같고 어, 비트코인 피어리드
인덱스는 항상 후행적이기 때문에 익신
F어 구간에 어, 지금 구간에 어,
안착을 했고 한 10일 정도를
기록하고 있고요. 어, 24일
기준으로 어, 이게 좀 업데이트가 좀
덜 된 거 같은데 한 400m년 정도
유출이 됐습니다. 그래서 굉장히 흐름
자체는 안 좋다라고 보시면 될 거
같습니다. 어, 주의 쪽 보시면
어, 로즈앤 로즈앤 러이라는 데가
있다라고 합니다. 그 스트레티지에
대해서 조사를 착수했다라고 하는데이
뉴스가 어제 이제 폭락했던 그 시점에
나왔던 뉴스는 정확하게 아닌 거
같더라고요. 그
처음에 나왔던 뉴스를 여러 데서 이제
퍼르다 보니까 어제 밤에 조금 더
크게 어 반응을 했던 거 같은데 미국
로펌인 로젠가 어 스테스트와 창업자
마이클 셀러를 대상으로 오해 오해를
불러일으킬 수 있는 사업과 관련한
잠재적 증권 청구 가능성에 조사를
시작했다라고 합니다. [콧방귀]
정확이 어떤 내용인지 디테일 그렇게
나오지 않았기 때문에 정확히 무슨
내용인지 좀 더 어 후속 보도가
나와야지 정확히 알 수 있을 것
같지만이 이슈가 어제 하락을 좀
메인으로 끌어내렸다라고 생각을 하고
있고요. 로젠가 주주를 주주를
대신해서 어 잠재적인 증권 사기를
조사한 유명한 투자자 관리 전문
로폼이다라고 나와 있고 홈페이지
들어보니까 주로 증권 관련된거나
체제적 권리를 대상으로 어 주로 쌓아
주더라고요. 그래서 그런 어 전문
로폼이 붙었다라고 보시면 될 거 같고
스트레티지와 세일러가 사업 회사의
사업에 대한 오해를 불러일으켜지는
주장에 대해서 주장을 했는지에 대한
여부가 관심이 집중이 되고 있습니다.
그래서 스트레디가 지금 하고 있는 뭐
연구 우선주를 통해 자금을
조달한다든가 아니면 비트코인을
자신들의 어 애피타이즈에 맞게 그냥
뭐 판다든가 이런 식의 그런 어
말들이나 그런 주장들이 또는 사업
계획이 어 좀 올 오해를 불러일으킬
오해를 불러일으켜서 어 주주들의 조금
피해를 입혔는지 그런 것들을 좀
조사할 확률이 굉장히 큰 거 같다라고
보고 있고요. 어이 문제를
스트레티지만의 이슈로 보기만 어려운
것이 어 모방자들이 많이 생겨났기
때문이다라고 또 나왔습니다. 이
모방자라는 거에 어 스트레티지 같이
비트코인을 어 매입하고 좀 지키는
그런 회사도 많이 생겼지만
스트레티지의 상품을 오히려 매입하는
그런 회사도 많이 생겼거든요. 그래서
그런 것들이 조금 어 역하게 엮겨
있다라고 보시면 될 거 같고 상장사를
포함 상장사와 비상제를 포함해서
수십계 기업들이 스테지와 같이
비트코인 보유전에 수집하고 있기
때문에 연세적인 파장이 수 있다는
점에서 굉장히 상징적인 사건. 왜냐면
어 로젠가 예를 들어 스트레티지가
문제가 있다라고 했을 때 어 다양한
기업들 스트레티지의 모델을 따라하는
기업들은 거의 다 문제가 있다라고 정
사실화가 되는 거기 때문에 그런
부분이 사실 그 상징적이에다 볼 수
있을 것 같고 최근에 스트레티지와
STIC를 견해한 공격들이 진행되던
와중에 좀 지금 굉장히 크리티컬한
국면을 어 맞이하고 있는게 아닌가
하는 생각은 개인적으로 하고
있습니다. 그래서 예를 들어서이
모델이 문제가 있다라고 하면 직접
완벽하게 유사하진 않지만 그 비트
마인 이더리움을 모으는 비트
마인한테도 지금 공격적인 피해가 갈
거다라고도 볼 수 있을 것 같습니다.
그래서 왼쪽 위에 있는 사진부터
보시면 그 스트레티지 아 STRC의
가격 흐름인데요. STRC가 거의 한
74불 정도까지 내려오면서 역사 가장
최악의 흐름을 지금 맞이하고
있습니다. 주로 내려간다고 하더라도
80불대 아니면 원래 평균적으로는 한
90불대 정도까지 하회를 했었던
모습을 보여줬었고 그럴 때마다
배당률을 좀 올리는 어 그런 흐론을
계속 보여줬었는데 이게 지금 74불
거의 20몇 % 하락 그 100불의이
패깅이 조금 깨져 있는 상태다 보니까
어 그 약세가 계속 지속된다라고 보면
될 거 같고 어 MSTR도 굉장히
흐름이 안 좋습니다. 거의 최저가를
기록하고 있고 거의 90불 초반
그리고 80불 어 중반 정도까지
내려와 있는 상황입니다. 그래서 이건
흐름 제작 굉장히 안 좋다라고 보시면
될 거 같고 어이 흐름이 안 좋았던
건 계속해서 저희가 알고 있기 때문에
근데 만약에 정말 스트레티지
쪽에서이음
화려한 피날레를 장식한다라고 하면
어떻게 터질지는 전하게 예측하긴 좀
어려운 거 같습니다. 스트레티지가
파산한다거나 이렇게 어 끝난다는 건
좀 생각을 해 본 적이 없기 때문에
그런 부분들이 할 수 있는지 좀
검토해 볼 필요는 있을 것 같지만
어쨌든 지금 현재 스트레티지가 버티지
못하는 상황은 아니다라고 보고 보고
있고 제가 오히려 한 언급드렸지만 그
주변 기업들 스트레티지보다 돈이 없고
인기가 없고 어 뭐 다양한 뭐
기관들이 붙어 있지 않은 기업들이
훨씬 더 위험하지 스트레티지 같은
경우에 대주주 같은 경우에도 뭐
JP모고 블랙락이나 다양하게 붙어
이미 있거든요. 그래서 그런 기업들이
지금 팔고 있지 않은 상태이다라고
보여지기 때문에 그런 부분에 조금
견조하지 않나 생각은 하고 있지만
어쨌든 다양한 어이 유소한 모델을
하는 기업들은 굉장히 위험할 수 있다
이렇게 보시면 될 거 같습니다.
그리고 밑에 왼쪽 밑에 있는 보실
보시면 그 200주 이평선을
이탈했다라고 다양한 곳에서 보도가
나왔습니다. 200주 이평선 항상 어
깨고 내려왔더라도 다시 한번 반등해서
올라가는 어 그런 모습을 계속
역사적으로 보여줬었는데 그 구간에
다시 한번 왔다. 그래서 안을 거
같았지만 역사적인 패턴을 계속
반복하는 것을 봤을 때 어 22년의
패턴을 한번 보시면이 200일선을
하회하고 나서 바로 반등하지
못했습니다. 어이 부분을 어 꽤 오랜
시간 어 계속해서 유지하면서
지켜내다가 그다음에 반등했던 모습 어
제가 기억하면 기억하고 가면 될 거
같고요. 그리고 어제 다시 한번
변동성이 좀 그 격화가 됐던 이유는
계규모 옵션 만기가 예정이 되어
있습니다. 한 11년 정도의 옵션이
만기가 예정이 되어 있기 때문에 그런
부분들도 좀 영향을 미치지 않았을까
하는 생각은 개인적으로 하고
있습니다. 어쨌든 저도 마무리 한번
드리자면 결국에 아까 말씀드린 것처럼
어 시장이 어 정말 바닥을 찾기
위해서는 지금 거의 다 니 정도로
포함 표현하는 사람들이 많은 거
같아요. 어네 무릎 정도다. 아직
무릎 정도밖에 안 왔다라고 표현하는
사람이 굉장히 많은 거 같습니다.
그래서 어 아직 결국 누구도 그 어
이런 만 그 니라고 말하는 사람들도
이렇게 말하더라고요. 결국에 바텀을
찾았을 때는 그러니까 이게 너인지
아닌지를 판단했을 때는 이미 바닥에
나오고 나서였다라고 말을 하는
사람들이 많았는데 어 저도 비슷하게
생각하는 부분이 있습니다. 이게
바닥인지 아닌지는 정확하게 모르는데
어쨌든 이렇게 지금 센티먼트가 너무
악화가 되고 제가 올해 연초에이
ETF는 이제 비트코인의 매수에 아예
영향을 없다라고 그리고 오히려
스트레티지가 최대 매수자로서 시장에
지금 영향을 굉 굉장히 크게 보여주고
있다라고 말씀드렸었는데 그 스트레테지
그 유일한 스위처의 스트레테지가 좀
공격을 이렇게 많이 받고 있는 걸
봤을 때 이번 피날레 스트레티지로
시작된 어떤 큰 이슈가 하나
발발되면서 마무리가 되지 않을까는
생각은 개인적으로 하고 있고 이런
부분은 어 굉장히 긍정적이라 보면서
오히려 비트코인 자체의 시장이
좋아지는 것보다 비트코인 자체가 지금
위험 자산에 거의 대표를 하고 있는
그런 자산으로서 아 그럼 하반기 쪽에
왔을 때는 주익 시장이나 더 위험
자산 선호 장세가 더 펼쳐지나 이런
아이디어는 조금 나올 생각이
나더라고요. 그래서 그런 부분들로
봤을 때 어 하반기가 조금 기대가
되는 부분이 아닌가 하는 생각은
개인적으로 하면서 마무리 드리면 될
것 같습니다. 이상입니다.
>> 감사합니다. 왼쪽 아래 그 200주
이평선 이렇게 보여 주셨는데
200주면 대략 4년 정도 되는
건데요.
>> 이게 어 코인 가상업 비트코인
반감기하고도 연관이 있다 이렇게 봐도
될 걸.
>> 어 그렇죠. 네. 그래서 정확하게 그
말씀 주신게 4년마다이 사이클이
방각이 정확히 4년마다 이런
식거든요. 그래서 그런 부분들도
정확하게 심리에 미치지 않나 심리
영향을 미치지 않나? 기술적으로
영향을 미치지 않나 생각합니다.
>> 음. 네. 증시에서는 무릎이면 이제
분할 매수 시작인데
>> 어 어떻게 가격이 움직이는지
봐야겠으나 보다 관심 있으신 분들이
조금 더 관심을 높여야 되는 수준까지
가격이 내려온 것 같다라는 생각이
듭니다. 오늘 가상 재산 여기까지
보도록 하고 1부 마치겠습니다. 일부
함께 해 주신 채밀턴 여러분
감사드리고 잠시 후 2부에서
뵙겠습니다. 감사합니다.
>> [음악]
>> 안녕하십니까 채밀턴 여러분. 행복한
투자 요정을 함께하는 체슬리 모닝
브리프 이부도 잠시 제가 진행하고
잠시 후님과 교체하도록 하겠습니다.
어 전일 미국 시장 우리 유리프로랑
대략적인 아주 명료한 요약까지 했는데
좀 디테일이 더 있으실 것 같아서
초보 사장님께 들어보겠습니다.
아, 예. 전반적으로
그
빅테크와 반도체 어, 소프트웨어와
IT 인프라 이런 쪽에 극명한 대립을
나타내는 그런 하루였고요. 그리고 그
시그널로 어 애플이 제품 가격을
오르면서
요즘 흔히 말하는 얘기로 칩플레이션
칩의 가격이 너무 비싸 가지고 그것이
인플레이션을 유킬 정도라는 얘기까지
나오고 있는데 반면에 어 그런
부분들이 어 계속해서
반도체 메모리 쪽에 모멘텀을 더욱더
강화시키고 있는 그런 상황인이었던 거
같습니다.
소프트웨어 쪽에서 판란티어가 어제도
5.5% 하락해서
YTD로 어 40% 정도가 빠졌고요.
그리고 너빈 같은 경우도 33.8%
오라클 21.1% 하락 로비는
17.4% 4%라 이렇게
하락을 하고 있는데 아 이게 수급의
영향일 수도 있고 또 그동안
밸루에이션을 많이 받았던 어 기업들이
앞으로 밸류에이션 축수가 일어날 수
있다는 우려일 수도 있는 거
같습니다. 그래서음
전반적인 경제 자체가 인프라가 이끌고
있는 그런 경제고요. 그리고 아 그
반도체 쪽의 투자 모멘텀이 계속
지속되고 있기 때문에 아 이런
양극화가 일어나지 않나 싶은데 어
필반지수 내에서도 보면은 어 조금 더
모멘텀이 강한 쪽하고 모멘텀이 약한
쪽하고 나뉘는 거 같습니다. 그래서
제가 볼 땐 앞으로의 그 필반 지수의
방향성은 이전만큼 뭐 급하게
오른다기보다도이
안에서도 좀 차별화가 나타나지 않을까
싶습니다.
어 필반 지수 3.6% 6% 올랐는데
그 이전 같았으면 좀 심리가 좋았을
땐 다 오르고 다 뭐 그 상승률도 뭐
비슷비슷하게 갔을 것 같은데 어제는
특히 어 마이콘 테크놀로지가 실적
발표하면서 그쪽에 모멘텀이 강화되는
구간이었기 때문에 일단 마이콘
테크놀로지가 어 필반 지수 내에서
신고가를 기록을 했고요. 그리고 저장
장치인 아 샌디스크가
신고가를 기록을 했습니다.
그 이외에 어플라이드 머티리얼
테러다인 장비주 쪽에서 또 어
신고가가 나왔습니다. 그래서 어 일반
지수 내에서 한 세 종목 정도 그리고
일반 지수가 아닌 샌디스크가음
그 신고가를 기록을 했고요.이 신고가
개수가 조금씩음
줄어들 수도 있을 것 같아요. 제가
볼 때는. 그래서 어 경쟁력가 없고
돈 못 버는 회사들은 철저히 또
필반지수 내에서 어 배제되고 그렇지
않은음
돈 잘 벌고 어 밸리에이션도 뭐
적당히 어 경쟁 우에 따라서 확장될
수 있는 어 그런 기업들은 또 계속
주가가 오르는 어 구간이 이어질 것
같습니다.
M7이
처참하게 좀 빠져 빠진 날이었는데
M7을 추종하는 ETF 동일 가중으로
구성한 ETF가 있 MS라라는
ETF가 있는데 그냥 오래 들어서 한
7.4% 정도 하락을 했고요. 뭐
필반 지수는 잘 아시겠지만 소스 같은
경우 107.6%가 %가 상승을
했습니다. 그리고 소프트웨어가
여전히 좀 헤매고 있는 상황인데
IGV라고 하는 어 소프트웨어
ETF가 오래 들어서 19.8%가
하락을 했고 그리고 데이터 센터
인프라로 구성된 이태프가 47.25%
% 그래서
M7하고 필반 지수 소프트웨어하고
데이터인 센터 인프라 또는 하드웨어
뭐 이런 쪽에 그 극명한 대립이
나타나고 있는 거 같고 미국 시장에서
그 구경제 주식들이라고 하는 어
에너지나 필수비제나 뭐 산업제나 어
소재 유틸리티 요런 쪽은 그냥
그럭저럭 어 사이드워을 하고 있는
그런 상황인 거 같습니다.
그 마이크론 실적 발표에 따라서
밸루에이션하고 어 그리고 마이크론이
어 필반스 전체에 어느 정도 영향을
줬는지 좀 어 그 EPS 측면하고
주가하고 멀티플 측면에서 가져왔는데
실적 발표로 주가가 좀 급등을
했고요. 어쨌든음 그리고 EPS
추정치도 13%가 상향 조정이
됐습니다. 아, 그 이전에 보면 어,
마이크론이 한 열배 내외에서
거래가 됐었는데 어제 EPS정치
큰폭의 상향 조정으로 인해서 PER은
어 19.2 2배 정도 어 수준에서
거래가 되고 있습니다. 최근 고점은
11.2배였고요. 2배였고요. 그래서
어 주가 상승만큼이나
어 이패정치도 가파르게 상향 조정되고
있다. 그래서 어 PR은 주가
상승만큼 이렇게 비싸지는 않고 있다.
이렇게 이해를 하시면 될 거 같고요.
어 필반 지수 같은 경우도 마이크로는
실적에 영향을 받아서 이패 수중한
0.8% 정도 상향 조정됐고
PR이 27.7배 7배 거래가 되고
있습니다. 아 최근 고점이 29. 어
3배 수준이라 가지고
어 그렇게 뭐 만만한 PR는
아닙니다.
그래서 실적 발표가 뭐 7월부터 있을
것 같은데 그쪽에서 얼마나 EPS
상향이 되느냐에 따라서
PR도 좀 결정이 되지 않을까
싶고요. 그리고 머니멀도 이제 금리
수준 자체가이
그 PR 고점에 있는 기업들한테
어 압박을 줄 거 같은데
[목을 가다듬음] 어제 그 5월 달에
5월 PC 물가가 나왔는데
시장 예상치하고 동일하게 나왔습니다.
그러면서
물가에 대한 약간 경계감이 어 조금
완화됐다고 어 볼 수 있을 것 같은데
헤드라인 PC가 어 4.1%가 1%가
나왔고 근원 PC가 3.4%가
나왔습니다.
보시면은이
에너지 쪽이 5월 달에
아 에너지 쪽이라기보다도
아 에너지 쪽이 5월 달에 보시면은
어 에너지 꿀스 앤 서비스 보면은
24.3%가 3%가 YY로 증가를
했기 때문에 아이 부분이음
영향을 주었을 것 같고 그리고
에너지하고 [목을 가다듬음]
주거비를 제외한 PC 서비스 물가는
3.9%로 굉장히 끈적끈적한
편입니다. 그래서이 이후에 그 물가
상승 압력을 받는다면 제가 볼 땐 어
유가의한 에너지 상승보다는
상승보다는이
서비스 쪽의 물가 상승 압력이 어
전반적인 물가에 영향을 주지
않을까라고 생각을 합니다. 그래서이
부분을 좀 잘 봐야 될 거 같고
에너지 가격에 의한 물가 상승 압력은
5월에 픽아웃 할 걸로 저는 보고
있습니다. 그래서 어 그 이러한 물가
발표에 의해서 페드와치의 시장 반응을
좀 보면은 약간 매파적인 분위기는
진정이 되지 않았나라고 보 보는데 그
이유는 6월 18일 날
그
금리 인상 동결 어 정도를 보면은
7월 29일 날 FMC가 또 열리는데
이때 동결
확률을 를 61.5%로
봤고요. 지금 보면은 67.9%로
9%로 좀 올라갔습니다. 그리고 어
올해 연내 금리 두 번 인상 정도가
6월 18일 정도에
시장에서 생각했던 컨센서스였는데 어
지금은 한 번 정도로 어 좀
낮아졌고요. 그리고 그 확률 자체도
어 조금 더 그 한 번 정도 인상으로
더 가고 있는 거 같습니다. 이건
계속해서 체크를 해 봐야 될 것
같고요. 지금 상황에서 단원하기는 좀
어려울 것 같습니다.
그래서 어 헤드라인 근원 PC가
이렇게 됐고 지금은 높아져 있는
상황이지만 헤들라인은 픽아웃 근원은
조금 끈적끈적한 상황이 이어지지
않을까라고 보는데 가솔린 가격 보면은
5월대 5월을 피카 5월을 피크로 해
가지고 6월 달에 좀 내려온
상황이고요. 그래서이 부분이 전반적인
헤드라인 물가 완화에 영향을 줄 것
같습니다. 또
클리블랜드 연원에서 어 PC하고
CPI 어 물가를 추정하는데
공교롭게도
어 7월에음
FMC가
7월 29일에 열리는데요. PC
발표가 6월 PC 발표가 7월 30일
날 있습니다. 그래서 연 그 FMCS
연연준에서는
아 6월 PC는 보지 못하고 어
회의를 진행을 [목을 가다듬음] 할
것 같고요. 현재 클리블랜드 연원에서
추정하는 헤드라인 PC는 어 일단
5월에 나왔던 건 4.1%고요.
6월은 3.9%로 0.2% 2%
포인트 낮아지는 걸로 보고 있고 어
코어피 PC는 3.4 3.4로 어
똑같을 걸로 보고 있습니다. 그리고
어 CPI는 보고 들어갈 것 같은데
왜냐하면 CPI는 7월 6월 CPI가
7월 14일 날 발표가 되기
때문입니다. CPI는 5월에
4.2%에서
3.96%로
아 이것도 한 0.2% 2% 포인트
낮아질 걸로 보고 있고
어 코 CPI 같은 경우는 2.9에서
2.85로 어 살짝 내려올 걸로 보고
있는데 거의 비슷한 수준으로 유지가
될 걸로 보고 있습니다. 이걸 가지고
어 연준이 7월 29일 날 어 금리를
과감하게 올린다라고
판단하기는 좀 어려울 것 같아요.
그래서 어 일단 헤드라인 쪽에서
픽아웃하는 것만으로도 어 좀 동결
가능성이 저는 높지 않나라고 보고
있습니다.음
음. 그리피 아 1분기 GDP
확정치가 나왔는데 여기에서 볼 수
있는 어 간의 임플리케이션은 투자
관점에서 지금 미국 GDP를 이끌고
있는 것이 어 민간 투자 기업 투자
쪽이기 때문에 그쪽에 추세가 계속
이어지는지 어 살펴보고 그렇다면 투자
관점에서 설비 투자나 장비 투자나 아
이런 쪽에 경쟁의가 있는 어 기업들은
계속 모멘텀 을 가질 수 있다는 것이
제 생각인데 어 PC가
확정치가 2.1%가 나왔는데 어
잠정치가 원래 1.6%였습니다.
PC 같은 경우는 속보치, 잠정치,
확정치 이렇게 됐는데 이번에 확정치가
나온 건데이 0.5% 5% 포인트를
끌어올린 거는 수입 쪽에서
수입액 자체가 조금 줄어 가지고이
부분이
1분기 GDP를 좀 끌어올린 거가
됐고요. 나머지는 어 옆에 이제
기어율 보면은 미국의 소비 자체가 한
GDP에서 70% 정도 차지하는데
기어율 자체는 상당히 낮습니다.
1분기에 낮았고요.
오히려 인베스트먼트 쪽이 어 1%대
초반이나 그 기어유 기어를 하는 어
그런 상황인데 대충 보면은
미국 GDP 구성이 소비 쪽이 한
70% 어 민간 투자가 한 20%
비중 그리고
정부 지출이 한 20% 비중 그리고
어 넷 엑스포츠 쪽이 -10% 해
가지고 100% 정도 되는데 그러니까
20%의 비중을 차지하는 라는 어
인베스트먼트 쪽이 민간 투자 쪽이
이렇게 큰 기회를 하하고 있다는 거는
아 굉장히 그 규모의
그 증가가 어 가파르게 나타나고
있다는 그런 의미일 거라고 어 추정을
할 수 있고요. 어 그 밑에 이제
본문별 기열도에서 어 비거주 투자
부문에서
난 레지셜 쪽에서 이먼트 쪽이 그
IT 장비나 AI 서버나 반도체
데이터 센터 하드웨어 쪽을 나타내는
건데 그 추위를 보면은 22년 1Q
2Q 3Q 4Q 1Q 쪽에 이제 한
1% 정도 기어했고 그다음은
0.2에서 한 0.4% % 정도
기어를 했었는데 이번 1큐 쪽이
0.88%가 88%가 기여가
됐습니다. 그래서 이쪽이 상당히
가파르게 어 지금 확대되고 있다고 보
그 볼 수 있는 것이 그 GDP
쪽에서 본문별 기어도에서 어 확인을
할 수가 있고요. 옆에 리키먼트 쪽에
분기별 추의를 보면은 어 각도가 조금
상당히 가파르게 나타나고 있다는 것을
또 여기서 제차 어 확인을 할 수
있습니다. 그래서 이걸로부터 얻을 수
있는 좀 어 인플리케이션은 뭐냐면 어
반도체 장비쪽 대표적으로
반도체 지수에 있는 어플라이드
머티리얼이나 램리치나 ASML, KL
그리고 테러다 어 이런 기업들의
어 주가 자체가 어 실제로 GDP에서
어 차지하는 장비 쪽에서의 지출이
상당히 가파르게 늘어나면서
결을 같이 하고 있다는 거를 어 볼
수 있는데 뭐 어플라이드 머티리얼 어
램리서치 올해 130에서 160%
정도 올랐고 어 밑에 ASML은 뭐
72% KLA하고 테러다인도 한
100에서 140% 정도 상승한 거를
볼 수 있고 그보다는 조금 상승률은
덜한데 어 건설 전력 쪽에서
PWR이라는 티커를 가진 회사가
있는데이 회사가 퀀스 서비스인데요.
미국 최대 전력 인프라 건설 및
유지보수 기업입니다. 뭐 자세히
리서치는 안 해 봤는데 어쨌든
컨셉상으로 보더라도 어 이런 장비
투자가 늘어나면서 건설 전력 쪽에서의
모멘텀도 계속 유지되고 있다고 볼 수
있는데 어 퀀터 서비스가 올해 70%
올랐고요. 어 캐터필나 어 중장비
어 건설 업체인데 어 중장비 어 제조
판매 업체인데 이쪽에서도 어 84%
올랐고요. G번호가 잘 알려진
회사인데 가스터빈 쪽에서 글로벌 1위
사업자인데 66%가 올랐습니다. 뭐
메모리나 반도체 장비 쪽보다는 조금
상승률은 덜하지만 어 계속해서 꾸준히
올라갈 수 있는 모멘텀 정도로는 어
체크할 수 있을 것 같습니다.
이상입니다.
>> 감사합니다. 오늘도 평소와 똑같이
어디서도 볼 수 없는 우리
부사형님만의로 데이터를 가공해서
자료를 보여 주시니까
>> 예
>> 어 좋아요.
[웃음]
>> 감사합니다.네 네. 오늘 공부도 많이
됐고 밑에 표는 이따 다시 한번 그
말씀을 좀 보면서 제가 몇 가지
질문을 드릴 것 같은데
>> 한국으로 치면 마치 수출입 통계
분석하듯이 이렇게 분석을 해 주신 거
같아요.
>> 예. 그렇습니다.
>> 예. 위에 그음 필라델피아 반도체
지수 30 종목이 보여 주신 표 보면
>> 아 그냥 제 추정인데 엔비디아부터 맨
밑등까지
>> 요게 아마 필반 지수 내에 구성 비중
순으로 아마 나열를 해 주신게
아닌가? 거의 뭐 비슷합니다. 거의
비슷한데 어 주의해야 될 거는
TSMC가 ADR로 상장돼 있잖아요.
그렇기 때문에 그 필반 지수의
어 편의 비중 자체는 16위 정도
됩니다. 왜냐면 필반 지수는 어 그
유동 시청 비중으로 하고 있거든요.
그래서 많은 분들이 이제 SK
하이닉스가 필반 지수에 들어가면 어
엄청난 영향력을 미칠 거다라고 말씀
생각하시는 분들이 있는데 실제로 유동
시종 비중으로 하면은 어 하이닉스가
필반 지수에 미치는 영향력은 그렇게
크진 않습니다. 음
>> 참고로요. 예, 여기 그러면 어 아마
그 필반 지수도 인덱스 지수니까
>> 정기적으로 리밸런싱을 할 텐데
>> 어 이런 시총 변화 때문에 예컨데
이제 뭐 다음이 언젠지 모르겠는데요.
리밸런싱 할 때
>> 마이크로는 좀 비중이 많이 올라가고
이렇게 좀 바뀌겠습니까?
>> 예. 그렇죠. 그렇죠. 바뀌지. 그건
당연히 어 바뀔 거 같고요. 지금
>> 샌디스크가 들어올 수도 있고
>> 아 샌디스크가
아 샌디스크가 지금 필반 지수가
아닌데
>> 여기를이이
회사가 일반 지수에 왜 못
들어갔는지는 잘 모르겠는데 아 최근에
웨지털로부터 25년에 분사를
했잖아요. 분사를 했고 또 비슷한
결에 웨슨 비슷이나 C게이트 이쪽으로
좀 묶여서
>> 어 이쪽을 이제
>> 좀 억지스러 억지스럽긴 한데 제가
채피에서 찾아본 바로는 반도체 순수
반도체라기보다도
저장 장치 쪽에 가깝다라는
이유로 필반질수에
>> 성격이 안 맞는다.
>> 예. 성격이 안 맞는다라고 얘기를
하는데 제가 볼 때 센디스크가
필반주수에 들어가도 전혀 무리가 되지
않는다고 생각합니다.
>> 어쨌든 어 뭐 분사한지 얼마 안
됐고음 뭐 저장 장치로 분류가 돼서
필반 지수 성격이 안 맞는지는
모르겠지만 네
>> 그 예 나스닥이나
뭐 SP 500에서 지대한 영향을
미치고 있는 것은 사실입니다. 음.
마이크론도 쑥 다시 비중 올라갈 수
있고.
>> 예. 지금 필반지수 내에서 한 4위
정도 되는 거 같아요.
>> 네.
>> 알겠습니다.
>> 어, 그리고 그다음에 이제 물가 지표
짚어 주셨는데 우선음
>> 몇 페이지죠?요
6월 18일, 6월 25일요 표가
있는게 3페이지 2페이지인가요?
3페이지죠? 예. 요걸 이제
보여주셔서 제가 어쨌든간 증시는
금리가 올라가면 밸류에이션이 좀
박해지기 때문에
>> 네.
>> 어, 좋은 건 아닌데
>> 예.
>> 어, 금리를 생각보다 빨리 많이
올리면 어떡하지? 이런 생각하고
있었는데 요렇게 로데타를 근거로 어
요렇게 조금씩 시장 기대치보다 물가
지표들이 같거나 조금씩 낮게 나올 수
있어서 어 금리가 인상되는 시점은
지금 생각하는 거보다 좀 뒤로 밀릴
수도 있다라는 취지로 말씀을 주셔서
조금 더 이제 안정이 됐습니다.
>> 어 그냥 저희가 조금 상상력을 좀
발휘해서
>> 예
>> 이제 월별 PC 지표가 위에
있는데요. 네.
>> 어, 잘 마무리가 중동 관련한
이슈들이 잘 마무리가 되면 적어도
이제 에너지 관련한 그런 기업은
계속해서 이제 음수 쪽으로 될 거고.
>> 어, 그래서 만약에
>> 예,
>> 물가가 어, 우리가 지금 보고 있는
물가가 여기 보시는 것처럼 4%
안팎인데
>> 예.
>> 어, 4%에서 3.5%를
>> 가는 한 6개월에서 1년을 보여
준다면
>> 예. 그러면 우리 부사장님 생각에는
어 금리는
>> 내리진 못하지만 그냥 쭉 옆으로
동결하면서 갈까요? 어떨까요? 아,
저는 동결하면서 간다고 생각을
합니다.
>> 왜냐하면 음,
그러니까 아, 그니까 물가의 영향을
주는 것이 아, 공급 요인이 있고
수요인이 있잖아요. 그러니까 공급
요인 쪽에서 공급 충격이 생겼을 때
어, 가장 쉽게 생각할 수 있는 것이
어, 육가 쪽이거든요. 유가 쪽에 어
충격이 생겼을 때 그것이 어 물가를
자극하고 금리를 자극하는 부분이 있을
거고요. 그리고 어 수요 요인이라고
하면은 경제가 굉장히 강했을 때 그
수요가 견인하는 인플레이션이
있잖아요. 어 그것 때문에 물가를
자극하고 어 금리를 자극할 수 있을
것 같은데 지금은 공급 요인 자체는
좀 완화되고 있고요. 수요인 자체가
어 어제 그 GDP에서
보면은 어 미국에 이제 소비 비중이
굉장히 큰데 소비가 GDP에 기여하는
부분은 극기 줄어들고 있고요.
>> 그리고 어 대부분이 지금은
AI 인프라 투자 이쪽 민간 투자
쪽이 아 GDP 성장을 이끌고
있잖아요. 그래서 약간 어 쥐디 그
수요가 견인하는 물가 자체가 소비도
강하고 투자도 강하고 정부 지출도
강하고 수출도 강하고 이렇게 막 모든
부분이 다 강하게 나타날 경우에 어
물가가 생각하지 못한음
수준으로 어 수요가 수요에 의해서 어
상승이 견인이 될 수가 있는데 지금은
강한 쪽이 어 민간 투자뿐이라
제가 볼 때는 수요가 견인하는 물가
상승이 일어나는 거는 좀
제한적이다라고 보고 있습니다.
>> 그렇게 되면 사실 금리가 올라도
주가는 더 좋고 되게 좋은 건데요.
>> 예. 그렇습니다. 그래서 어 물가
자체가 그 공급 요인이 좀 완화가
되고 수요인도 좀 그럭저럭 전 부분이
아닌 어 민간 투자 쪽에 의해서
견일이 된다면 제한적이지 않을까라고
생각을 하고 있고 어 그렇게 되면은
금리가 오르는 수준 자체도 어 그냥
계속 그
특별히 뭐 한 4%에서 4.4%에서
4%에서 왔다 갔다 하는 그런 수준이
되지 않을까? 근데 여기서 이제
4%를 뚫고 내려가려면은
어떤 요인에 의해서 유가가 굉장히
세게 빠지거나 아니면 어떤 요인에
의해서 경제가 상당히 좀 안 좋아지는
쪽으로 가야 되는데 어 그런 극단적인
상황을 조금 지금 상황에서는 어
가정하기는 좀 어려운 거 같습니다.
>> 감사합니다. 어 작년 작년 9월로
기억하는데요. 골드만삭스가 그 팬데믹
이후 그니까 2022년 이후
지금까지를 포스트 모던 사이클이라고
이렇게 네이밍 이름을 붙이면서 어
금리가 생각보다 못 내려오는 상황
밸루에이션은 늘 보면 꽉 차 보이는
상황 그런 상황에서 우리가 어떤
투자를 해야 되느냐라고 얘기를 했는데
어 부산장님이 언급해 주신 그 정확한
텍스트를 워딩을 하진 않았지만
>> 어 전체적인 시장의 움직임이 가는
곳에
쏠림 투자가 있을 것 같다. 그래서
지수에 지수에 투자해서 기대하는
수익률보다 업종이나 종목을 택해서
기대하는 수익률이 훨씬 더 중요한
시대가 오는 것 같다라고 얘기하고
이미 어느 정도 시작은 됐지만 AI
관련한 어 진짜 IT 하드웨어 반도체
업종 그리고 그 주변에 있는 인프라
관련한 구경지 업종 이런 데서 픽을
하면
>> 알파 오퍼니티가 굉장히 많은
>> 어 시기가 오는 것 같다라고 얘기를
해서
>> 어 작년 9월에 제가 그 글로벌
인사이트 우리 어스 플랫폼 인턴분들께
말씀드린 기억이 있고 그것에 대한
업데이트가
>> 6월 16일 날 또 나왔어요. 제가
촬영 맞춰서 이번 주 주말에 아마
나갈 텐데.
>> 어, 내용은 뭐 이렇게 비슷한
내용이지만 그래도 지난 어떤 경과가
있었는지 그럼 이렇게 많이 진행된
지금은 이제부터 또 어떻게 해야
되는지에 대해서 제 의견이 아닌
골든상스 의견을 좀 요약을 드렸는데
>> 어, 인턴 분들을 보시면 많은 도움이
될 것 같습니다. 홍보했습니다.
>> 그럼 그럼 결론부터 얘기해서 지금부터
어떻게 해야 된대요?
>> 일요일 날 나간다니까. [웃음]
하 급해. [웃음]
>> 네. 어, 결론은 뭐 살짝 말씀드리면
>> 예.
>> 어, 미리 내리지 마라.
>> 그런 취지에 예. 그런 취지에 여러
가지 로데이터와 예, 메시지를 주고
있.
>> 지금까지 그 세대로 했다면은 그대로
해라. 그런 얘기.
>> 네. 네.
>> 그 저 자꾸 쪼지 마시고 그들
[웃음] 보세요.
>> 예. 알겠습니다.
>> 마지막으로 예. 제가 분명히
기억하는데 여기 그 PC 추정
클리블랜드 연준 연는
>> 추정요 표 보시면서
>> 수년 전에 저희이 모닝 브리프 초기에
어 FOMC를 전후해서 CPI는 보고
들어가는데 아 죄송합니다. 그 저기
저기 그죠. TPI는 연준이 보고
들어가는데 PC는 며칠 차이로 못
보고 미팅을 한다.
>> 근데
>> 정말 모를까 국가 기관인데 뭐 아
진짜로 2, 3일 차인데
>> 그래도 비공식적으로론는 다 알고
FOMC 회의하지 않을까라고 얘기를
저희가 나눴는데
>> 그때 부사장님이 아 근데 진짜 미국은
모르고 회의하는 거 같다라고
>> 그 피드백 주셨던 기억이 있어요.
그래서
>> 정말 선진국인 거 같다. 어, 여전히
그런가요?
>> 뭐 제가 정확히 알 수 없는데
[웃음]
>> 그렇게 믿어야죠. 네.
그래서 어 이제 추정해 주신 대로
이게 이제 PCE 물가까지 다 보고
어 미팅을 하면 금리를 올려야
된다라는 의견이 보다 더 부드러워질
수 있을 것 같은데 어 그런 부분들도
또 관점 포인트가 아닌가는 생각이
듭니다.
>> 예 오늘 그 귀한 자료 잘 정리해
주셔서 여러 가지 또 힌트도 없고
궁금한 것도 여쭤봤습니다. 미국 시장
여기까지 보도록 하고
국내 시장으로 넘어가 보겠습니다.
오가장님 부탁드립니다.
네. 전유 시장 말씀드리겠습니다.
코스피 5% 가량 상승세로 마감을
했었고요. 코스닥 2%대 약세로
마감을 했습니다. 수급적으로 보면
개인 투자자 2조 4천억가량 차액션에
좀 나서는 모습이 나왔었고 외국인은
뭐 연일 매도세는 유지가 되고 있는
상황입니다. 어제도 한 8억 가량
매도가 있었고요. 기관에서는 3조
3천억 가량 어 매수세가 위됐습니다.
[콧방귀]
메인 선물에서 2조 8천억가랑 매도가
있었는데요.
또 장 막판 들어가면서 매도가 굉생히
확대가 되더라고요. 그저께도
그랬었는데 어제도 비슷한
영상이었습니다.
투자자별 매매 동향으로 보면 외국인
투자자는 어제 LS 지주 그리고 LG
이노택, 알테오젠, LG 전자 서신
서진 시스템 등을 매수를 했었고요.
반면 매도에는 SK하이닉스 3조
6,억가량 매도했었고 그 외에 SK
스퀘어 전자, 전자 우선주, 현대차,
삼성전기 등을 매도했습니다.
기간 매수에는 삼성전자 약 1조
가까이 매수했고요. 그리고
SK하이닉스 9,억 정도
매수했습니다. 그 외에는 삼성전기,
알테오젠,
전자 우선주, 삼성 물산, 리노 등을
매수했었고요.
기간 매도에는 어 어 그저께와
마찬가지로 ETF만
보입니다.
네.
어, ETF가 지배하는
시장이 되어 버렸습니다. 어, 뭐
항상 느끼고 있는데 저희가 점심
먹으면서 아, 약속 있어서 이제
점심을 먹으면 점심 먹기 전에 한번
아, 지금 이런 흐름이나 한번 보고
>> 한 저희 사실 점심 빨리 먹으니까
>> 뭐 20분, 30분 내 다 먹고 다시
보면
>> 확 바뀌어 있어요. 그런 경험 아마
요즘 많이 하실 텐데 그래서 밥
먹다가 사람들이 막 어질어질하다
그러고
>> 아 이게 뭐 이게 보고 있는다고 사실
답이 있는 건 아닌데 안 보고 있으면
추세 예측이 잘 안 되고 그러니까
계속 불안감이 있는데
>> 이제 운용하실 때 우리 광의사는 요즘
좀 어떠십니까? 어떻게 마인드 확인을
하십니까? 말씀인 것처럼 매일 어지럽
일단은 근데 지금 같은 장에서는
솔님이 사실 극단으로 계속 왔다 갔다
하는 상황이잖아요. 네. 올라가는
종목만 계속 올라가고 등등하는데 네.
이럴 때 일술로 올라가는 종목들은
사실 다 이유가 있는 그런 올라감이
나오는 거고 그리고 반대로 올라가지
못하는 것들 안에서도 저희가 구분해서
봐야 될 거는 아 얘네들이 실적이
진짜 망가져서 못 올라가라는 건지.
네. 그래서 만약에 그렇다라고 하면은
교체 매매도 한번 고려해 볼 수도
있을 것 같고. 근데
[목을 가다듬음] 그런게 아니라 진짜
실적은 어 2분기나 3분기나 내년도의
실적이 깨지지 않은 거 같은데
그러면은 사실 또 들고 가야 되는
상황입니다. 그래서 그런 식으로 어
포트폴리오를 [콧방귀]
어 어느 정도 계속 체크하면서 가야
되는게 아닌가 중심을 잘 잡아야 되지
않을까라고 개인적으로 그렇게
생각합니다. 네. 저희가 운용을 해
보면 어 개인 자금이면 특히 정말
개인이 본인의 자금을 운용을 할
경우에는 어 종목에 대한 어떤 내가
투자한 기업에 대한 믿음과 그 투자에
대한 가정이 깨지지 않았으면 좀 버텨
보실 수가 있는데 기관 투자자 같은
경우에는 이게 어떤 로스컷 규정 어떤
기간에 대한 상대 평가에 대한 규정
이런 것 때문에 어쩔 수 없이 지금
팔면 안 되고 지금 사면 안 되는 거
알면 면서도 그런 매매를 하게 되는
경우가 사실 많아요.
>> 음.
>> 게다가 이제 지금 분기말,
반기말이어서 그렇죠.
>> 그런 매매들이 좀 더 극심해지는게
아닌가?
더는
좀 해보게 됩니다. 그래서 이럴
때일수록 갖고 계신 기업들 종목들에
[목을 가다듬음]
대해서 잘 체크해 보셨던 어떤
이유들이 흐트러지지 않으면 조금 더
인내를 해 보시는
>> 것도 필요한게 아닌가? 오히려 인내를
하는게 유연한게 아닌가는 생각도 좀
해보게 됩니다.
>> 작정
인내보다는 [웃음]
>> 공부를 해야 될 것 같아요. 아 무
물론 이제
>> 그
인내의
그 기반에는 공부가 바탕이 돼야 될
것 같은데 무조건 이제 그 좀 안
좋은 케이스가
>> 계속 빠지다 보면은
>> 그니까 흔히들 하는 실수가 이제
비자발적 장기 투자잖아요. 그러니까
좀 외면하게 되고
이런 때가 굉장히 좀 그 난이도가 어
높은 구간인데 음
>> 내가
실수나 잘못을 인정하고 반성하고 아
그거를 바꿀 수 있는
>> 음
>> 용기가 저는 인내보다도 더 필요하지
않나 싶습니다.이 이 잘 되면은 이제
어 그거를 계속 어 끌고 갈 수 있는
뭐 있내 용기 필요한데
>> 잘 안 되는 경우에 어 실질적인 어떤
문제가 뭔가 이런 거에 대해서 한번
더 본 다음에 진짜 잘못 봤다라고
하면은 어 그거를
모르면 팔아야지 어떻게 되면 팔아야지
그런 시나리오나 가정을 두기보다는
>> 어 바로 그
잘못이나 실수가 어, 발견됐을
인지됐을 때는 바로 액션을 하는게
맞는 거 같습니다.
>> 음, 맞습니다. 제가 외국인 큰
연기금 투자자 말씀을 드려서 몇 번
말씀드린 적이 있는데요. 어, 가만히
포트폴리오를 유지하는데 아무것도 안
하고 유지하는 것과
>> 온갖 진실된 고민 이후에 가만히 있는
것이 큰 차이가 있습니다.
그렇습니다.
>> 예. 그냥 가만히 있는 건 안 되죠.
>> 예. 단적으로 예를 들어서 내가
A라는 종목을 어 샀어야 되는데 잘못
알고 B라는 종목을 샀어요. 근데
얼마 후에 아 그 실수를 인증을
했어요. 아, 그런데 어, 주가
방향성이 어떻게 되던간에 저는 그거는
이제 바로 잡아야 된다고 생각을
하는데 어, 주가가이 내가 산 비가
많이 빠져 있어 가지고 어, 이게
너무 많이 빠졌으니까 올라갈 때까지
기다렸다가 사야지. 아, 팔아야지.
>> 또는 A가 어떻게 됐기 때문에 이거는
좀 기다렸다 사야지. 이 이거는
사실은 조금 더 악수를 두는 어
케이스라고 생각을 하거든요. 그래서
[목을 가다듬음]
>> 어 실수와 잘못 내가 방향성을 좀
잘못 봤다 이러면은 아예 그냥 그
>> 어 이세도의 책 책 제목처럼 어 판은
없는게 맞습니다. 세 판을 짜는게
맞습니다. 그게 사실 어 미래의 어떤
성과에 더 기여가 되고 어 개선이
되는 것이지 어 무조건 어떤
시나리오에 의해서 어 희망 고문에
의해서 어 버티는 거를 인내라고 봐야
되는 건 아닌 거 같아요.
>> 아니라니까요. 아니라고 제가
얘기했잖아. 예. 하겠습니다.
>> 오바장을 팔장 끼어서 이제 [웃음]
>> 얘기 그만하고 주요 종목 보도록
하겠습니다.
>> 네. 52주 신고가 말씀을 안
드렸는데
>> 아이고. 예.
>> 네. 코스피에서 삼성전자 우선주
그리고 SK 지주 SK 우선주가
신고가였고요. 코스닥에서는 기가비스
광진실업 이렇게 신고가가 났습니다.
그래서 최근에
>> 코스닥에 있는 반도체나 IT 장비
중에서 기가비스가 좀 탄탄한 것
같아요.
>> 주가 변동성도 상대 좀 그래서 최근에
계속해서
>> 신고가의 이름을 올리고 있는
상황입니다. 네. 주요 종목 보면
반도체 섹터 먼저 말씀드리겠습니다.
삼성전자가 오제 5% 가량 상승
마감했었고 하이닉스가 마이크론 강세
영향에 주가가 13%가량
급등 마감했습니다. 그리고 아래
소부장 쪽 봐 주시면 리노이 한 4%
정도 상승세로 마감을 했었고요. 주성
엔지니어링이 뭐 특별한 이슈 없이
8.5% 5% 가량 큰 폭으로 하락
마감했습니다. 그 주성이나 HPSP
이런 종목들 어 최근에 좀 주목을
많이 받았었는데 좀 어느 정도이 좀
빠지는 느낌이고요. 특히 HPSP는
더 그랬던 모습이긴 한데 테라이 아직
뭐 시작도 안 했는데 거기에 이제
장비 들어간다 이런 기사로 인해
>> 주가가 단기적으로 뭐 5, 60%가
올랐었거든요. 그래서 그런 부분이 좀
해소가 되는 국면이다라고 볼 수가
있겠고 어 심태이 한 7%랑 또
상승세로 마감을 했고 어제 긍정적인
리포트가 좀 나왔었던 거 같습니다.
그리고 IT 섹터 봐 주시면 삼성
전기가 한 1.7%가량 상승으로
마감했고요. 최근에 들어서 좀 상승
탄력 자체는 조금 둔화되는 흐름이
나타나고 있는 거 같습니다. 그리고
BH가 한 7%랑 약세 마감했었고요.
플랫폼 섹터는 네이버, 카카오 보합
정도의 등락 보이면서 시장 대비로는
조금 무진한 흐름이었고 니케이지수
어제 4.6% 급등 마감했습니다. 어
반도체 쪽이 확실히 좋았는데요. 도쿄
일렉트론이 7.8% 8% 급등세에
마감했고
>> 어 삼성전기의 피어라고 볼 수 있는
무라타랑 이비덴이 한 7%가랑 또
급등세를 보이면서 전기화는 조금
차별화되는 흐름이 나타났었고요. 또
어드반 테스트 15% 급등세에
마감했습니다.
자동차 섹터 봐 주시면 어제 현대차
1%대 약세로 마감을 하는
모습이었고요.
어, PL 10열배의 수준까지도
내려왔기 때문에 뭐 이런 구간에서는
좀 그래도 관심 가져 볼 만 하지
않나 그런 생각이 좀 듭니다. 소비제
섹터는 대형화 약세였고요. 아래
중소용화도 대체로 부진한
흐름이었습니다. 반면에 피오 미용
기기는 요즘에 좀 혼조세인데요. 좀
번갈아가면서 올라가는 거 같아요.
클래시스 2.3, 파마가 한 6%
큰폭의 상승세를 기록을 했고 아래
음식 섹터는 농심은 보합 정도 3시
남식품
1.9% 가량 상승으로 마감했습니다.
그리고 아래 백화점 체인 상당히
좋았었고요. 백화점은 그냥 요즘은
반도체 관련주로 보는게 맞지 않
듭니다. 반도체로 주가 많이 올라가면
사람들이 소비 진작이 되기 때문에
>> 네. 합리적인 논리 실제로 그게
효과가 나타나고 있습니다.
>> 그런 눈빛으로 동의를 원하면 어떻게
동의를 안 합니까? [웃음]
>> 동의의 문제가 아니라 현실입니다.
>> 네. [웃음]
>> 네. 조선 철강 미키색 더 봐 주시면
조선주들 어제 대체로 약세로 마감을
했고요. 화학이나 철강은 계속 좀
재미없는 상황이 이어지고 있는 상황
이어지고 있습니다. 그리고 최근에 뭐
유가가 좀 많이 하락하다 보니까 S이
좀 약세로 전환을 한 상황이고요.
>> 강산주들은 어제 뭐 특별한 이슈 없이
주가는 되게 부진한 상황이었습니다.
드라이 넥스1이 오늘 오전 오전에 장
열리기 전 아 지금 한 30분 전에
나왔는데요.
5,억 정도 유상증자 계획을 발표를
했습니다.
>> 음.
>> 어. 네. 거게 특별한
사유에 대해선 공시해 보니까 나오진
않는데요. 어 아마 102 케파가 좀
부족한 걸로 알고 있거든요. 그래서
>> 쪽 관련해서 증자 증설하기 위해서
증자한게 아닌가 그런 생각이 좀 들고
뭐 주가가 어떻게 움직일지는
지켜봐야겠지만 전 악재보단 좀 더
호재로 받아들이는게 좋지 않을까 그런
생각이 좀 듭니다. 그리고 로템이나
주사 어 요템이나 하나 요쪽 약세
보였고요. 로템 17배까지 떨어졌기
때문에 많이 내려와 있는 상황인 거
같습니다. 바이오섹터는 어제 대형
바이오는 나쁘지 않은 흐름이었는데요.
코스닥 바이오 쪽이 좀 안
좋았습니다. 페트론이 16%가랑
음급락하는 모습이 좀 나오기도
했었고요. 여긴 없지만 리가 바이오도
오늘 아침에 좀 이슈가 있었는데요.
국민 상장 펀드에서
어 리가켄 바이오 쪽으로 좀 투자
유치가 들어간 거 같아요. 오리온이랑
좀 같이 해서 들어가는 거 같은데
오리온도 그 바이오 투자를 이전에도
좀 했었던 걸로 알고 있는데 그래서
오리온이랑 고민 성장 펀드가 같이 좀
투자하는 걸로 이야기 뉴 뉴스 기사가
나왔습니다.
>> 그리고 증권주 쪽은 어제 키움 증권이
그래도 7%가랑 좀 급등하면서 최근에
주가가 굉장히 좀 안 좋았었는데
반등세를 좀 시현을 한 거 같고요.
엔터 쪽은 좀 여전히 좀 정신을 못
차리는 거 같긴 한데 파브가 3%
하락했고
뭐 나머지 엔터배까지
다 빠져서
어 뭐 밸루에이션 관점으로 너무나
매력적인 상황인데 시장 상황이 좀
녹록치 않은 거 같습니다. 직용주
쪽에 대한 솔림이 해소되기는 쉽진
않아 보여서
장기적으로 보는 투자자라면 이런
구간에 뭐 현대 로템 같이 많이 쌓진
방산이나 이런 애터 쪽시품 이런 거를
본다면 좀 향후 1년 2년 후에는 좀
수익으로 다가올 수 있지 않을까
생각이 듭니다. 변합기 쪽은 현대
1을 제외하고 약세였습니다.네
감사합니다. 왼쪽에 반도체 소부장
IT 이렇게 광의의 하드웨어 IT
하드웨어 쪽만 보면 어 그래도
소부장은 최근에 조정을 좀 많이
보여서
>> 몇몇 기업들을 제외하면
>> 제가 몇 주 전 혹은 몇 달 전 봤던
막 전부 다 50배, 60배, 70배
이건 이제 아닌 거 같데 다 많이
내려왔고
>> 그냥 쭉 이렇게 눈으로 여기 보여
주신 종목들 봤을 때 한미 반도체
주성 엔지니어링 삼성전기 정도만 좀
아직 눈에 튀는 밸류에이션이고 나머지
지들은 과거에 저희가 좀 봤던
수준까지 좀 내려와 있다 이렇게 좀
보여집니다. 어, 그리고 오른쪽에
있는 종목들음
맨 위에
어, 현대차부터 이렇게 쭉 봤을 때
어, 이게 뭐 시클리컬이냐 아니면
여러 가지 그 어, 사업 모델이나
경쟁자와의 경쟁 관계냐 이런 걸 다
보긴 해야겠습니다만 그냥 대략적으로
1배 미만으로 떨어진 종목들이 많이
보이는 거 같아요. 그래서 그런 것들
>> 어 이렇게 눈에 걸리는 것들이
있으시면 항상 좀 이렇게 어
포트폴리오가 분산될 때 그런 종목들
위주로 어 보시면 어떨까 하는 생각이
드는데 아직까지는 어 외국인들이
집중적으로 매도함에도 불구하고 반도체
투탑과 그 주변주들로 매기가 모여
있는데 요게 언제이 언와인딩 될지에
대해서 그래도 계속 시간이 갈수록 더
높은 비중으로 모니스터링을 해야 되는
건 맞는 걸 생각을 해봤어. 예.
그렇게 이해를 하고 좀 넘어가도록
하겠습니다. 어, 오늘 두 가지 또
리포트를 갖고 오셨는데 첫 번째가
하마리서치인데요
제목이 어떤 CF죠, 이게?
>> 네. 네. 네.
>> 키움 증권 CF
>> 어,
>> 들어보겠습니다.
>> 네. 다울 박종현 연구원님
자료인데요.
어 설명할 시간이 없다고 합니다.
그래서 어서 타야 된다라고 하는데
뭐 이런 비슷한 이야기가
작년에도 좀 있었던 거 같아요. 주가
많이 이제 내려오기 시작했을 때 이건
기회야
>> 파마리서치네.
>> 네네.
>> 뭐 파마도 그렇고 사명식품도 그렇고
좀 그런 류의 제목이 좀 많이
있었군.
>> 음. 일단 내용을 좀 살펴보면 미주한
브랜드 및 마케팅 투자와 화자품 부분
성장이 시장 기대치를 상하는 매출로
이어질 수 있겠다라는 전망했고요. 어
다만 마케팅 투자로 OPM은 소폭
하락할 수도 있겠지만 영업 레버리지를
통한 회복을 좀 기대해 본다. 추정치
상향으로 적정 주가는 54만 원으로
잡았는데요. 2분기 실적에 대한
코멘트입니다. 매출 1750억대
영업이 670억 나오면서 YY나
QQ로 이익과 매출 모두 그 두
자릿수 이상 증가할 것으로 추정을
했고요. 그래서 매출 기준으로 컨센을
상해 영업 이익은 부합 정도 나오지
않을까라는 전망입니다. 의료 기기부은
646억으로 YY 6% 뭐 QQ로
11% 정도 증가할 것으로 보고
있고요. 지난해 2분기 의료파업전
시술 빨라지면서 평균이라는 어
기저에도 불구하고 Yi 성장을 기원
시현을 좀 기대한다. 어 4월 5월
의료관광 피부 소비 금액이 각각
1408억과 1452억으로
어 y 60% 80% 성장으로 역대
최대 금액을 경신한 가운데 관광의
일본은 일본 효과 및 내수 웰스
이펙트 효과에 따른 피부과 소비금의
우상한 기조는 그래도 좀 유지가 되지
않을까라는 전망했습니다. 경쟁심마에도
불과하고 동사 MS 유지 가능하다라는
판단이고요. 매출 성장 확대 기존은
유지가 될 것이다. 그래서 의료 기기
수출 267억 정도 전망이 되고
있는데요. YY 10% Q 26%
정도 나오면서 위롭쪽으로도 어 확장이
좀 나오지 않을까라는 전망했습니다.
화장품 쪽이도 그리고 굉장히 좋은데
화장품 매출 180억
정도 추정이 되고 있고요. YY
60% 키오케 18%기 때문에
화장품도 고성 장세가 좀 나타나지
않을까는 전망입니다. 그리고 인바운드
위입에 따른 B2C 면세 매출 증가
좀 기대하고 있다라고 하고요. HB
채널량 매출 증가가 실적 성장에
기여했지 않을까라는 전망입니다.
수출 400억 정도 나오면서 YY
105% QQ 49%의 좀 고성장을
기대한다라고 하고요. 동남마 및
유럽, 동유럽 채널 매출 증가 추세가
좀 나올 거 같고 미국과 중국 셀로라
입점 및 채널확장 효과를 기반으로 한
매출 성장이 나오지 않을까는 전망까지
했습니다.
수출 데이터를 좀 보면 4, 5,
5월 수출의 YY 69%, 64%
성장한 것으로 추정이 되고 있는데요.
화장품 비중 증가에 따른 믹수 변화로
GPM 75.6 나올 것으로 보고
있습니다. 그래서 인건비 광고비
증가로 OPM은 조금 낮아질 것으로
현재 추정을 하고 있고요. 리즈란
브랜드를 기반한 화자품 부분에서
가파른 성장이 나타나고 있다라고
하는데 어 전망이 마케팅으로 OPM
하락하는 전망이지만 영업 레버리지에
따른 점진적 OPM 개선 기대한다.
타겟 프라이스를 조금 올려 잡은 거
같습니다. 네.요 밑에 표도 혹시
설명해 주실 내용이 좀 있습니까?
네. 의료 기기 쪽 성장이 올해
YY로 한 17% 나올 것으로 추정이
되고 있고요. 의약품 쪽은 워낙
비중이 적기 때문에 좀 스킵해도 될
거 같고 화장품 쪽이 고성장세가
유지가 될 것으로 보고 있는데요.
지난해 70% 올해도 한 60%로
큰폭의 성장세 기록할 것으로 추정이
되고 있는 거 같습니다. 그래서
화장품 쪽은 AP도 그렇고 파마리
서치도 그렇고 지금 뭐 북미 쪽에서
좀 잘 나가는 편이잖아요. 근데
어쨌든 의료 기기 쪽이 그래도 좀
중요한 건데 일단 성장률 자체가
지난해
려왔다는게 조금 아쉬운 상황인 거
같고요. 그래서 내수는 사실 이제
숫자 자체는 나쁘진 않은데 시장에서는
내수에 대한 의심을 계속 하는 거
같아요. 경쟁사위 진입이라고 해서 어
제 이름이 잘 기억이 안 되는데
>> LNC바이오
>> 아네 LNC바이오를
>> 비롯한 회사들의 경쟁 사진입을 좀
우려하고 있는 움직임이 주가에서 좀
나타나고 있는게 아닌가 그런 생각이
좀 듭니다. 오른쪽은 5월 외국인
의료 관광 피부 소비 금액
추위인데요. 외국인들이 일단 계속
많이 들어오고 있고 특히 중국인들의
입국이 많아지고 있기 때문에 중국
비중이 지금 굉장히 높아졌습니다.
서요 올해
어 지금 5월 기준으로 외국인 관광객
중에 중국인 미중이 한 33%까지
올라온 상황인데 중국 관광객들은
국내에 들어와서 피부용 시술을 많이
하기 때문에 이런 부분을 기대해
보자라는 거 같고요. 아래는 강릉시
분기별 수출액 추위인데
뭐 그렇게 좋은 트렌드 흐름은 아닌
거 같습니다. 지난해 2분기를
기점으로 수출이 크게 증가하거나 그런
움직임은 나타나고 있지 않기 때문에
수출 쪽의 증가율 자체는 좀 많이
내려온 상황입니다. 그래서 뭐 아직
수출이 본격화되지는 않았기 때문에 그
부분을 이제 하반기 그리고 내년
가면서 확인해야 되겠다라는 생각이 좀
들고요.데 뭐 당장 기대하기는 좀
어렵지 않나 이런 생각이 들었습니다.
자, 이승준 대표에이어서 제가 뿅하고
나타났습니다.
자, 밑에 그림도 있는데 그림도 좀
설명해 주시죠.
어, 설령 방금 드렸습니다. 그래.
>> [목을 가다듬음]
>> 자, 외국인 의료 관광 피부가 소비
금액 추의고어요
부분이 우리나라 내수 시장에 있어서
굉장히 큰 하나의 어 모멘텀이 될 수
있다라고 생각하는데 어제도 제가
최근에 주식 강의나 어 설명을
할까면이
국내 유통은 저는 평생 앞으로 이제
투자 안 할 거다라고 생각을 했다가이
외국인 관광객이 지금 6월 끝나지
않았는데 는데 벌써 천만 명이
넘어요.
>> 천만 명이 넘었고 2019년에 많이
들어왔을 때가 이제 1900만 명이
좀 넘었었는데
어 보통 주식을 할 때 제일 중요한
단어 중에 하나가 구조적 성장이냐
구조적으로 이제 약세로 바뀌는 거냐
예 그런 부분인데
유통은 저는 구조적 약세로 변했기
때문에 앞으로 볼 일 없다. 네.
온라인반이
유통 채널 때문에 아마존이라든지 쿠팡
때문에
외통수에 빠진 회사 이러지도 저러지도
못하고 리뉴얼을 안 하면 더 후져
보여서 강남에도 보면 백화점 전체가
이제 텅텅 비어서 망한 막아요.
그래서 리뉴얼을 안잔히
망하고 해도 손님들은 와서 아이쇼핑만
하고
그렇게는 전자 선거에도 다 주문을
하는 그런 외통수 상황이기 때문에 아
주제할 일 없겠다 싶었는데이
관광객들이 밀려들면서
뭐 관광객들이
소비 소비가 시작됐는데 진짜 많이
들어와요. 보면 어 중국 관광객이 한
260만 일본 관광객이 한 160만
그렇게 근데 이게 끝났느냐라고 보면이
관광 계획 3천만 시대로 가는
거거든요. 그 2천만에서 3천만
원으로 간다면
배팅을 해 볼 만한 거죠.
자, 그래서이 백화점
최근 저 최근에 뭐 신세계 백화점을
비롯해서 차트를 보면 꽤 강하게
올라가는 그런 모습이 보이고
아직까지는 요쪽에 대한 얘기들이
많지는 않지만
그 구조적 성장에 턴어라운드가 되고
있는데 보통 턴어라운드 주식 투자하기
힘들다잖아요. 예. 피터인치가
턴라운드 주식까지 투자를 잘하셔
가지고 굉장히 제가 종량을
어떻게 보면 요쪽은 턴어라운드가
시작됐다. 그 턴라운드의 모멘텀은
뭔가
울밀듯이 들어오는 건강게
이제 핵심인 거 같고요. 여기 실적
추정 표가 나오는데 그래서 실적은
실적이 그래서 숫자로 나와
이거잖아요. 예. 숫자로 나오는지는
이제 동기 실적마다 나오겠죠.
그래서 탑라인이 증가하고
경쟁이 치열하면 탑라인이 증가해도
마진율이 못 올라올 거예요. 탑라인이
증가하고 이익이 같이 증가한다.
결국은 어 주가는 다시 돌아서게 되는
그런 부분
국면으로 진입할 거기 때문에 근데
설명할 시간이 없어. 어서해야 될
정도예요.이 리포트가
>> 내용을 보면은 사실
어서라고 하기에는 조금
>> 그러니까 내용은 뭐 그렇지는 않은데
>> 요즘 좀 연구님들이 재밌는 제목으로
하는 걸 좀 즐기시는 거 같아. 요즘
미미나 이런 걸 또
>> 많이 쓰시기도 하는데 저 내용 제목
보고 어그로 끌려서 이제 바로
클릭해서 봤거든. 음.
>> 근데 [목을 가다듬음] 뭐 기존에
나왔던 리포트들 큰 차이 없는
>> 내용이었습니다.요
>> 부분 왕박사는 어떻게 생각해요?
저번에 그 얘기 해 줬잖아요.
>> 네.
>> 한국에서 비행기 타고
>> 아 네네.
>> 한국 와서 호텔 숙박 다 하고 명품
쇼핑해도 중국에서 사는 것보다 오히려
낫다고.
>> 예. 우와.
왜냐면 요즘만 너무 많이 오고
있어요. 그 매니저들 많이 오고
있어요. 중 홍콩 아니면 중국
내려주고 와서 여기서 뭐가 뭐 탐방도
하고 삼성자 닉익스 할 때는 탐방도
하고네
>> 되게 많았었어요 요즘에
>> 뭐 뭐 뭐 그냥 많이 모를 수 있다고
생각하고 가성비도 죽어요 지금 그리고
일본 가는 그 피비자 피자 그
신청하는 거는 또 되게 비싸졌어요.
가는 거네 다배하는 다섯 배 정도
인상했어요.
>> 와
>> 예 그래서 여기 여기서 오는 거는
훨씬 더 나다고 생각할 수 있고 어
저도 뭐 승수기는 거의 방하
시점이잖아요 지금 방하시즌 아마
대하들이 많이 와서 얼굴까지 그 뭐
이런 거는 시을 많이 받아 가능성이
있다고 생각 네쪽으로
보 다 좋아요. 다 조되었고요.
그 어쨌든 한번 배화전에 대한 그
관연 거리도 확인 한번 해 봤어요.
뭐 뭐 이북이 싫죠. 어떻게 됐는지
대부분은 보화 수준 나올 수도 있고
그리고 추가적으로 쌈분기는 실전은
아마도 우상향 가능성도 있습니다.
>> 그래요.
>> 네.
>> 원래는 상분이 좀 약간 비숙이고.
>> 네. 다만 최근에 그 백화점
연세전으로는 약간 뭐 기대 이상 수직
계속 나올 수 있으니까 회사들이 되게
자신감 가졌어요. 3번기 또 좋다고
아니게.
>> 또 좋다. 네.
>> 그러니까 그 실적의 계절성을 보니까
1분기가 과거 사례로 보면은 1분기가
좋고 4분기가 좋더라고요.
>> 네. 2 3이 안 좋더라고요.
정체인들 기준으로 봤을 때. 근데
그게 왜 그럴까를 보니까 그 해외
여행을 많이 가는 시기인 거 같아요.
경기가. 아, 네.
>> 우리가 제가 [목을 가다듬음] 많이
가구나. 네. 네. 그렇죠. 근데
이제 지금은 환율이 높아 가지고 해외
여행을 예전처럼 그렇게 많이 가진
않을 것 같다. 그래서 최근에 레포트
나오는 것들 보면은 추정치가 2,
3분기가 많이 낮아져 있다가 어,
생각보다 컨텐서스보다는 잘 나올 수
있을 것 같네라는 얘기가 나와.
그래서 그런 현상이 있는 거
같습니다. 거기다가 관광객들의 효과도
있고 그렇죠. 네.
그리고 아까 제가 어 백화점을 또
실뢰했던 이유 중에 하나가 누가
소비를 할 건가인데이
우리나라 인구 구조가 지금
역삼각형처럼 되고 있잖아요.
>> 그러면 노령화가 되면 될수록 백화전
가서 소비를 하느냐? 아니에요. 저희
부모님도 마찬가지고
그래서 인구 구조적으로 봐도 아 국내
유통은 답이 없다 이렇게 생각했었는데
외국인들이 이제 몰려오면서 소비를
하기 시작점
주가가 저렇게 쭉 올라가면 그다음
수행납 하는 건 뭐지 하고 참 흐름이
쓰면 됩니다. 자, 그다음에는 이연택
연본 자료인데
제목이
알파 마이크론이 공개한 SCA와
케이크페이 믿을 수 있다.
>> 네. 어떤 얘기?
내용을 좀 살펴보면 랜드 플래시 폼이
꺾이고 난 뒤 있었던 일이라고 해서
본인의 경험담을 좀 이야기를 해
주셨는데요. 증권사 리서치 센터에서
애널리스트로 일하기 전에 반도체 부품
사업부 해외 영업 팀에서 한 3년
정도 어 일을 한 적이 있었다라고
합니다. 입사 당시 경원님
>> 네네.
입사 당시에는 랜드 플래시품이 막
꺼지던 식이었고 어 재고가 창고를
넘어서 추차장과 클린룸까지 가득 사일
정도였다라고 하는데요. 어느 날 해외
영업 본부장은 이미 고객이 추화중단을
요청한 물량까지 모두 화물기로
추가하라고 지시를 했다라고 하는데
제품이 추화되지 않으면 매출로
인식되지 않아서 실제 큰 타격이 좀
불가피했기 때문이라고 합니다. 마치
비밀 작전처럼 당일 저녁까지 모든
제품을 공항으로 보냈고 뮤고액들이
출근에 추라 사실을 확인하면서 큰
혼란이 좀 벌어졌었다라고 하고요.
지금은 관행이 달라질 수도 있겠지만
바도시 사이클이 꺾이면 구두 약속이든
장기 궁급 계약이든 힘이 급격히
약해진다는 점은 크게 다르지 않을
것이라고 생각한다. 결국 원학이
나빠지며 강호의 의리 같은 것은
없었다라고 합니다. 그래도 관행적인
책임분담은 있다라고 하고요. 고객사가
완전히 모르는 척을 하는 것은 아닌데
일반적으로 고객이 주문을 넣으면
그때부터 생산이 시작된다고 생각하기
쉽지만 실제 현장은 그렇게 단순하지
않다라고 합니다. 부품이나 소재
제고를 미리 확보를 해야 되기
때문이라고 하고요. 그리고 공정
안정성과 수요일까지 높이기 위해서는
어느 정도 예측 생산도 불가피하다라고
합니다. 실제 흐름은 대략 이렇다라고
하는데 먼저 고객사가이 정도 분량을
사용할 것 같다는 포캐스트가 있고요.
즉 연간 또는 분기발 수요 전망을
반도체 업체에 제공을 하게 되는데
그렇게 되면 반도체 업체는이를 근거로
원제로나 부품을 미리 확보하고 일부
생산 준비에 들어간다라고 합니다.
어항이 좋을 때는 이게 큰 문제는
아닌데 사이클이 꺾이면 문제가
발생하기 시작한다라고 하고요. 특히
해당 모델이 단종되거나 최종 수요가
극을 하게 되면 상황은 더
심각해진다. 일반 재고는 추가
지원될뿐 언젠가는 판매가 될 수
있겠지만 뭐 단정 모델용은 그대로
악성 제고가 된다라고 하고요. 결국
해당 제고를 헐값에 처분해야 되는 어
상황이 이르게 되고 그 과정에서
손실까지 발생하는 경우가 어 많이
있다라고 합니다. 다만 고객사도 이런
상황을 완전히 외면하지는 않는다라고
하고요. 개혁 조건과 협상력에 따라
차이는 있겠지만 고객 일부 보상을
지원하거나 향후 주문으로 손실을 메워
주는 경우가 있었다라고 합니다.
최근에 마이크론 실조 발표에서
SCA에 대한 이야기가 나왔잖아요.
이번 마이크론의 SCA와 테이크홀
페인은 기존보다 한 단계 더 강화된
구조라고 볼 수가 있겠는데 SA는
기존 LTA보다 구속력이 강한
계약으로 보인다라고 하고요. 고객이
단순히 퀘스트를 제공하는 수준이
아니라 특정 물량을 단연간 구매하기로
약속하고 취소 최소 가격까지 계약에
반영해 둔 구조라고 볼 수가
있겠고요. 여기에 테이크올 페이
조항이 붙었다는 점이 핵심인데 고의
약속한 물량을 실제로 모두 가져가지
않더라도 원칙적으로 일정 금액을
지급해야 한다라는 이야기를 했습니다.
그래서 마이크로는 14개 SCA의
어 자녀 계약 기간 동안 최소 배출이
약 1,000억 달러 정도 수준이라고
밝혔고요. 전체 SCA는 16개고
단순환하면 연간 200억 달러 이상
규모로 추정이 된다.이는 연간딜의
물량이 약 20% 랜드 물량이 약
30% 정도라고 하고요. 특히 중요한
것은 테이콜페이 조항이라고 볼 수가
있는데 과거처럼 수요가 줄었으니
추화를 미루자하는 방식으로는 리스크를
공급자에게 일방적으로 전가하기
어려워진 상황이다라고 합니다. 그래서
완전히 새로운 것은 아니지만 의미
있는 변화라고 볼 수가 있겠다라는
해석인데요. 과거에도 고객이 스크랩스
리스크나 일부 재고 손실을 부담하는
과정은 존재를 해 왔다. 하지만 이번
SCA나 테이크홀페이는 그 수준을
넘어선 계약으로 보여진다고 하고요.
고객이 단순 악성 제고에 일부를
보상하는 것이 아니라 메모리 가격과
물량 리스크를 장기적으로 함께
부담하기 시작했다는 점에서 좀 의미가
있어 보인다라는 의견입니다. 보이는
마이크론이나 하이닉스 삼성전자 같은
메모리 업체 입장에서는 과거보다 훨씬
유리한 계약 구조라고 볼 수가
있겠고요. 물론 마지막 사이클이
붕괴되는 시점에도 이러한 계약이
실제로 얼마나 강한 구속력을 갈지는
지켜봐야겠다라는 설명을 했고 하지만
현재까지는 메모리 산업의 구조가
과거보다 공급자에게 훨씬 유리한
방향으로 변화하고 있다는 점은 분명해
보인다 이야기를 했습니다.
그래서 어제 마이크론 실적 발표하고
부사님도 말씀해 주셨던 그 SC
테이크올페이이 이야기를 어 관련해서
[콧방귀] 이윤택 연구님 말고도
반도체 관련 애널리스트 분들이 여러
코멘트들을 좀 남겨 주셨거든요.
대체로 좀 비슷한 이야기를 하는 거
같습니다.음
밑에 표은 보니까 하이닉스 영업률네
분기 영업 익률 그래프를 가져온 거
같은데 2010년부터네
>> 맞습니다. 거고 영어 익률이
마이너스를 기록했던게 23년뿐만
아니라 저 앞에 2011년도에도 이네
>> 있었습니다.
>> 2011년도에 하이닉스가 SK
텔레콤으로
인수되는게 2011년 11월
보태였었는데
어 영업 이익률 유율이 적자가
남았죠. 그때 좀 안 좋은 모습.
2010년 11년 요때 엘피다도
망하고 인피니넘도 망하고 뭐 반도체
메모리에 구조 조정이 맞 마지막 이제
혹독하게 이루어지던 그런
시절이었었는데
그 이후에 이제 과점화 되고 나서는
영업 이익이 웬만하면 이제 적자로 안
들어가는 네
>> SK가 그때 신의 한수였었죠.
LG가 그래도 LG 반도체, 현대
반도체 합쳐서 만들어졌던 거기 때문에
계속 LG 전자에서 인수하지 않겠냐
얘기가 그때 나올 때마다 LG 전자
주가가 급락해 가지고 LG 그룹에서는
한사코 그런 얘기가 나올 때마다 아
우리는 안 산다. 그러다가 갑자기
SK 텔레콤이 사는 거예요. 당시에
한 3조 정도 주고 산 걸로
>> 음
>> 기억을 하는데
>> 지금 내년에 한 300조 번
>> 500조 500조 내년에 지금
500조 얘기 나오고
>> 그래서 그 신의 한수가 됐었죠.
자, 근데 이연태 경군이 자료를 항상
재밌게 잡는데 야, 옛날 반도체
해영업 근무할 때 이런 일들도 다
있었었네요.
>> 네.
고객이 오기 전에 그냥 일단 무조건
화물기로 출화해서 이미 출화됐다.
>> 예.
이것뿐만 아니라 중간에 반도체 유통
회사도 있잖아요. 그래서 메모리
업체들이
삼성 앞단에도 유통 회사 있었고
그래서 약간 매출이나 이런 걸 갖다가
조절하기 위해서 고객사 가기 전에
유통사한테도 밀어내는 경우도 있어.
일단 야, 요거 좀 어, 받아 줘
하면서
그런 것도 있고 업항이 나빠지면서
강호의 의리 같은 것은 없었다.
이렇게 돼 있는데 아무튼 지금 달라진
위상을 얘기해 주고 있다고요.
맞습니다.
저희 회사 고객분 중에서도 어 전자
임원 분도 계시고 하면서 지난번에
에피소드를 얘기를 해 주셨는데이
팀쿡이 아주 짜증을 내면서 화성이
했다는 거죠.
그동안에 큰 고객이었는데
너네들이 이렇게 가격을 쪼려 가지고이
가격 아이 가격 아니면 안 됩니다.
이런 얘기라 하니까 짜증을 엄청
냈다는 그런 에피소드 얘기했었는데
주식하면서 주식을 좀 쉽게 하는 방법
중에 아니라 제가 갑을 관계를
합니다.을
지금은 갑이 돼 있을까?을
을 갑이 되어 있을 때 하고
갑이었는데 갑의 위치가 아닐 때 팔고
그래서 지금은 마이크론 사이넥스
삼성전자가
아주
그게 위상이 바뀌었다고 됐더라고 본
말씀 이재용 회장님의 위상이
바뀌었다. 마이크로 오늘 책임자가
애플 팀한테 한마디로 했는데
>> 예
>> 너네들이 우리가 힘들 때 단가를
토르쳐서 우리는 굶어 죽을 뻔했다.
어 했어.
>> 어
>> 그들은 늘 최고의 마지막 생각하는데
우리도 투자하기 어려웠다. 얘기야.
>> 그러니까 그런 얘기를 할 수 있는
위치가 된 거죠.
>> 야
>> 나중에 어 꺾이면 마이크로는 죽었네.
이제 [웃음]
어
나이가 들면 이거 되게이 속에 담게
되거든.
>> [웃음]
>> 그래서 말을 아껴야.
>> 어 말을 아껴야돼. 근데 팀 교체되지
않나요?
>> 교체됐습니다. 예.
>> 아 교체됐고
>> 그런데 새로오신 분도 그 얘기
마이크론 얘기를 이제 들었을 거예요.
그죠?
>> 삼성전자 하이닉스한테는 호재입니다.
제가 보니까.
[웃음]
오른쪽 표가 보니까 이비에다
에비티치네요.이 마이크론이 전자
하이닉스 대비 약 50% 활정에
거래되고 있다. 지금도 아직까지
그래요.
>> 네. 에비따 기준으로 아 에비
기준으로 그 PR 기준으로는 뭐
30% 정도
40% 정도
거래되고 40%나
>> 40%까진 아닌 거 같고
>> 한 열배
>> 아홉배 정도 떨어졌더라고요.
>> 아 아홉배까지
>> 예 아홉배 정도 떨어졌어요.이 이패수
그 상향 조정이 크게 되면서 20%
정도
>> 예 % 정도
>> 여기는 지금 파란색은 삼성이고
중앙색이 하이닉스고 까만색이
마이크론인가 보네.네
>> 맞습니다.
>> 예 그래서 그 EB 에빗 기준으로는
7.4배
하이닉스가 5.2배 3승이 4.배 어
요런 것들죠.
>> 예
잘 안 보는 지편. 예. 어쨌든
그건 비싸게 걸어야 되네요.
알겠습니다.
자, 제가 조금 있다가 9시
35분부터 한국경제TV
화장 연결을 해야 돼 가지고
[목을 가다듬음]
>> 그 자료 마지막
>> 자료 만든다고 좀 있는게 들어가셨는데
잠시 뒤에 시청하시면 되고요.
>> 어, 주요 내용은 그겁니다. 이번에
캡 소형주 차트 보니까 연초 이후
-10.7%
받았죠. 아,
>> 그리고 코스닥 -4%
면초유.
>> 음.
>> 그 대형주 차트는 만 넘었더.
이런 차별의 원인 중에 하나가 보면
결국은이
중앙 글로벌 중앙은
정책이 긴축으로 이제 바뀌는 거
아니냐 이런 부분들이 영향을 주고
있기 때문에 거기다가 이제
케빈옷이라는 서로운 연조 내장이
단생을 했었고 단생이라게 보면 바뀌
그런게 과거 사례를 봤을 때 주식
지장에 어떻게
영향을 줄까이 지금 영향을 주고 있는
거거든요.
>> 그 부분에 대해서 좀 이따가 설명을
좀 해 드릴 생각나 시장은 어떻게
되고 있습니까? 어제 야간 선물은
어떻게 끝났었죠? 1점 8% 아
1.4%
아
>> 어
>> 마이크론이 15% 급등을 했지만
그거는 우리 시장에서 선반을 했으니까
>> 그래서 MSSI 사우스 코리아
E프트는 4% 올랐지만 야간 스물은
-1.45 마이너스로 시작했어요.네
-1.31%로
하락해서 출발했고요. 현재
-1.8%입니다. 1.8%입니다.
1.8%
코스닥은 어떻게 되고 있을까? 네.
코스닥 - 0.38%로 하락해서
출발했었고요. 현재 -2.24%.
음.
>> 오과장 자료에도 나오네요. 코스피
200원 올해 들어와서 139.9%
140% 갖고
>> 코스피 111% 갖고
>> 고스닥 마이너스.
자,
오늘 질문에도 아까 보니까 7월 달에
1만 포인트 달성이 가능한가 그런
질문도 있긴 했었는데
자 오늘 밤 미국 시장
어제
플러스 플러스 둘 다 플러스 날 거라
>> 그 마이너스 마이너스였습니다.
>> 마이너스 마이너스
>> 그 SP는 0.01 01% 하락이라서
>> 거의 딱 붙어 있더만.
>> 네.
>> 아, 근데 0.01 살짝 많이
넣어요.
>> 빅테크가 좀 많이 빠져서 그 지수가
좀 많이 빠졌던 걸로 보이고요.
시총이 크다 보니까.
그래서
오늘도
사실 음. 그까 필반은 계속 오르는데
필반은 3% 정도 올랐거든요.
>> 네. 나스닥이랑 SB는 아무래도
빅테크들
비중이 크다 보니까
많이 빠져서 또 올라올 것 같긴 한데
오늘까지는 좀
빠질 것 같습니다. [웃음]
올랐으면 좋겠습니다.
>> 나스닥이나 오늘까지는 좀 조정이
이어질 것 같다.
고
자 폴
>> 예
>> 예 우리 최부 사장이 세례명의
폴이잖아
>> 예 바울 바울은
>> 필 필반도
>> 예
>> 필반은
>> 필라델피아죠
>> 예 그런
일반 주스는 빠질 것 같아요 지금 예
중요 이벤트가 끝나 가지고
싶습니다. 습니다.
쉬어도 뭐 크게 이상하지 않은
관이라고 생각을 하고 있네.
>> 중요한 거는 이게 잠시 쉬는 거니까
>> 예
>> 여기서 팔았다가 뭘 밑에서 다시 살
정도의 조정은
>> 아닌 거 아닌 거 같습니다.
>> 그래서 어 옆으로
좀 기는 조정
>> 예정도
예상하시는 거죠? 예, 그렇습니다.
또 그
2분기 실적 발표들이 좀 프리뷰가
나올 수 있으니까 그때 뭐 본격적으로
조금 그 수장치로 움직일 만한
이슈들이 있을 것 같고 지금은
마이크론에 대한 관심도가 굉장히 강한
상황이고 임팩트가 너무 세 가지고 다
반영된 구간이 아닌가 싶고요.
조금 쉬는 구간이 있지 않을까라고
생각합니다.
그래서이 정도에서 사람들은
차익 실현 욕구를 좀 느낄 수도 있을
것 같아요.
예. 그래서 좀 하락할 것 같습니다.
>> 예.
자, 미국 시장은 SP 500이나
나스닥, 일반 모두 좀 조정을 받을
것 같다.
>> 미국이 조정받으면 오늘 우리 시장 좀
빠질 때 아, 오늘 밤에 미국 어차피
오를 거야 하면서
어, 지르기가 좀 애매하게 되는데
>> 코스닥 또 음봉이에요.
>> 네. 코스닥 음봉입니다.
>> 어제 어떻게 했어요?
>> 어제 음봉입니다.
>> 어, 어제 음봉이어요. 잘 맞추네.
뭐 코스피
어제 양봉 예상하고 양복 났죠. 네.
야, 어제 시초가도 막
시작하고 나서는 좀 막 흔들흔들
했었는데
[목을 가다듬음] 오늘 시장이
소부장말건도 완전 박살나는 시장이라서
>> 다 빠지네요. 시 빠진들도 많은데
단기적인 마이크론 실적 모멘텀이 끝이
났고 주가에 어제 다 반영을 한번
했기 때문에 오늘 금요일이기도 하고
해서 오늘 음봉 가능성이 좀 더 높지
않을까 싶습니다.
>> 아 오늘 그러고 보니까 금요일이네.
오늘은
>> 코스피 음봉 네
>> 상한다고 됐습니다.
어 저 거저께도 말씀드렸지만
>> 시장이 [목을 가다듬음] 지금은 어
좀 심리적으로 보면 전체적인 시장
분위기는 약대적 분위기에 그니까 약대
분위기고
>> 그러다 보니까 오히려 그 [콧방귀]
코로나 때 코로나 때 보면 처음에
빅세이라고
특정 대형주만 먼저 올라가거든요.
왜냐면 코로나라는 그런 상황이
발생하다 보니까 전체적으로 경기가
어려붙고 투자 심리도 어려붙고
>> 근데 유동성은
중앙은행의 재료 금리를 만들어 주다
보니까 돈은 풍부해지고 그런데 아
코로나 같은 상황에서
기업들의 매출이 급감하게 뻔하니까
>> 음
>> 그 상황에서 수익을 낼 수 있는
기업만
>> 음
>> 집중적으로 공략하게 되죠.
>> 그렇습니까? 그 희소해지죠. 코로나
같은 상황에서 돈을 버는 기업은
희소하다 보니까 그때 BBIJ,
바이오, 배터리, 인터넷, 게임 요런
업종들의 대형주가
특별히 쏠림 현상이 실내점에서
올라가는 그런 모습이 있고 지금은
아직까지는 그래도 금리 자체가 좀
높은 레벨에서 움직이고 있고
공황은행들이 다 금리 인상 기조로 좀
바뀐다. 싶으니까
>> 그러니까 좀 체력이 약한 기업들
>> 예 그렇습니다.
>> 그런 기업들이 주가가 최근에 좀 많이
빠지는 그런 모습을 보이는데
금리는 제가 예상을 해 보니까 하반기
들어가면 빠지겠더라고요. 다시 9월
8월 9월 언저리부터 오히려 금리가
좀 빠지는 모습. CPI 빠지고
>> 음
>> 그래서 이번이 그렇게
좀 이번 조정장이 또 주식을 싸게 살
수 있는 기회도
>> 결론은 그렇게
>> 좀 이따가 말씀드리자 좀
>> 전에 이제 투자 심리 말씀해 주셨는데
아 제가 매일 체크하는 지표 중에
이제 피엔 그린 넥스가 있는데 오늘
보니까 극단적 공포 구간으로
들어갔더라고요.
>> 아 25 이하로
>> 떨어졌어요. 네.
>> 예. 그래서 아침에 그 저희들이 어
매 첫 장에 보여주는 데이터를
보더라도 사실은 어 빅테크들의
아성이 조금 무너지는 좀 그런듯한 어
모습들이 관찰이 되고 있고 특히 어
케팩스 경쟁으로 들어가면서 지금 어
그 케펙스를 이렇게 언제까지나
공격적으로 할 수 있을지에 대한
오려들도 어 상존하는게 맞잖아요.
그리고 다른 기업들도 어 그러면은 어
같이 캐팩스를 하게 되면은 실적
자체가 나빠지지 않을까라는 우려들도
있고 그런 분위기들 자체가 어 그
투자 심리를 조금 투자 심리에 어
영향을 주는 거 같습니다.
그러겠네요.
>> 예.
>> 알겠습니다. 자 금요일이고요. 어
이번 한 주도 고생 많으셨고 6월도
이제 거의 다갔다고요? 나갔습니다.
>> 예. 안 남았습니다.
>> 또 우리나라 시장이 약한게 어제
어이없이 진 축구 때문에 약간
초자십니까? 약간 영향을 받은게
아닌가? 좀 맥빠지잖아요. 그렇죠.
그 주말 잘 보내시고 저희는 또
유리프로랑 저희는 내일 별주 부전에서
또 한 주간의 시장을 정리해 보는
시간 갖도록 하겠습니다.
>> 예. 오늘 채슬림 모인 브리프 6월
26일 순서는 여기까지 하겠습니다.
>> 고맙습니다.